you
[Music]
10 times 15 times
[Music]
elements of bathrooms
we're looking very strongly at sinks and
showers elements of bathrooms
10 times
[Music]
trump's white house toilet
would be clogged
[Music]
big massive
[Music]
[Music]
god bless
the united states thank you very much
elements of bathrooms
smarter
[Music]
that might come as a shock
[Music]
[Music]
mangoes
now that we are up under our bodies
regime
my bag of mangoes now cost 11.99
that seems like a pretty good deal a bag
of mangoes mango aren't measures like
three boxes
eight or 11 bucks
[Music]
bring my mangoes back down
[Music]
[Music]
the wisconsin crowd identifying with the
mangoes
forcefully affected the american people
don't want me to be healthy
healthy daughter wants me to be healthy
if highway
[Music]
right and we may even have fruit on
stream a little bit later welcome
everybody good morning good afternoon
good evening depending on where you find
yourself in the world today is the first
day of the confirmation hearing for joe
biden's first of
maybe one supreme court nominations
maybe more than one
katanji brown jackson's first day of
confirmation hearing starting in just a
few minutes very very important and
i don't know that i'd call it a
coincidence but
it is at the same time that this is
happening
right wing supreme court justice
clarence thomas has been hospitalized
with
flu-like symptoms now
it was some suggesting
speculating it might be covid
but he is being treated with antibiotics
which
doctors don't give for covid although
there are people who take antibiotics
for covet as many of you know talking
about zpacks
but in any case
supposedly being given antibiotics which
if they were prescribed by a doctor
would suggest it's not
covet so
that is happening and uh this is footage
from
prior confirmation to a lower court for
katanji brown jackson but at the top of
the hour the confirmation hearings are
going to start a lot of different things
going on at david pakman show
headquarters today um piers morgan has a
new show that is going to be launching
soon and i've been invited to be on a uh
an episode of it
um although it's not it's like a
practice episode which is really weird
but they're dangling they're like we'll
pay you to appear on a practice show
which is weird but also if the producers
like you you might be a regular guest
and it's like so you want me to take
time to just be on a show that won't air
that like i'm kind of busy
but they kind of dangle like no no but
sir then you might be a regular guest so
i'm thinking about doing that it would
only be a few minutes of my time um i'm
also going to be on the michael knowles
daily wire show coming up soon
um
there's a big documentary this is just
kind of weird but these are just things
that came across my desk today there's a
documentary being worked on by someone
about the disappearance of the malaysian
airlines flight 370 and i guess they
want to license a clip i some commentary
i did kind of interesting i don't know
they always you know with all of these
things the way these things work is they
go
would you be potentially interested in
uh us using that clip and like what
they're doing is they're trying to feel
out whether i'm gonna charge them for
usage of the clip right
so if you go yes i'm very interested
then they they typically just try not to
give you any money for the clip that you
produced
um
and
then
so you have to know how to respond and
usually my response is i'm potentially
interested depending on the terms of the
license
and then usually they'll offer you like
a hundred bucks and then you can be like
no sir that's crazy we need 20 grand or
you know whatever anyway these
negotiations always start
so that's going on i don't know anything
about the documentary quite frankly so
i'll keep everybody posted
um and then what else is going on i
guess that's mostly it we have a new
caller oh a couple things i guess real
quick someone sent me this this is kind
of funny this is not a real i don't even
know what modern day debate is
but this is like a fake promo for a
debate that is not really taking place
between myself and stephen kenneth
destiny benell ii is meme theft ethical
modern day debate what is modern day
debate does anybody know is that like a
debate series of some kind in any case
this is a joke we're not really going to
be debating this
yeah it'll be at one of these infamous
six hour debates where no one learns
anything
a streamer who does debate hosting
okay
anyway
so that's something
we also have a new oh i ha by the way
i do want to let people know
on today's stream i am using different
machines to stream and as you know
machines are very very much on the brink
of just being totally destroyed by mike
pillow's latest lawsuit we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines
so if at any point the stream shuts down
it may be because my my computer got
rocked
by mike pillow's latest um
latest stream
we've got a new coupon code new coupon
code as people are noticing this is a
today this is for this the hearings only
the coupon code is
fix the court we must repair the supreme
court it's a right wing nightmare
nightmare
fix the court new coupon code
first person to use it today it is a
heretofore unused coupon code first
person to use it gets a free item from
my online store okay so that isn't very
very
uh
observant
now the only problem is the coupon codes
are generated by a machine we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines so anyway the coupon code may
go down that could be a problem
um big thank you to rudeboy for the
twitch prime sub today i appreciate that
okay we've got a new caller
new caller this is a new caller okay
tell me if you like this one
david
do you really make a paycheck for what
you do sir in all seriousness yes
i just am appalled that that you would
you would
interrupt trump like you did right give
your commentaries that are ridiculous
these right-wingers who stumble across
my trump rally streams
expect me to sit here silently
you know like like uh
like a piece of wood throughout the
entire rally can you imagine not even
not even accurate and you just sat there
and you cringed you cringed it is this
great i did cringe that's true
entertain this crowd
you cringe you could you couldn't handle
it it's so funny you you were you
probably [ __ ] your pants in your chair
right and and and uh you know had your
little smirky smile on while you were
[ __ ] your pants you couldn't deal
with it right and and i couldn't deal
with all the great arguments trump was
making the the
camallo harris would would have a uh now
camella is the new that's a new they've
mispronounced kamala harris's name all
the time i've never heard camella before
but this is a pretty good new caller i
have to say you're a crowd than you
and you had you had trump by your side
god you're embarrassing honestly god are
you a soros uh ah
there it is there it is it's only it's
always only 30 seconds away
uh employee or whatever because you
can't be getting paid for what you just
did right
this
liberals aren't that that well this guy
partially paid me right i mean you know
i got when he watched the stream and an
ad was triggered
we earned a fraction of a penny from
that that [ __ ] up they can't be they
can't be you can't be that [ __ ] up and
get paid for what you just did right
i mean people really watch you yes
people really support you seriously it's
crazy i know but it was funny you cringe
dave come and join join our side so
anyway this went on for the full three
minutes and then then it ended abruptly
okay so then this gentleman called back
in again this is great i like this guy
um a message for you david pakman david
you you are a [ __ ] i i cannot believe
that i'm trying to watch the trump rally
i'm stuck listening to your commentaries
not only that he's calling me multiple
times he's got he's got hours invested
now in this thing that he can't imagine
anyone ever watching you are one
ignorant liberal a typical liberal you
gotta talk over somebody you can't let
trump speak are you that afraid of what
he says where you can't listen to him
maybe you'll learn something my friend
but you're a typical [ __ ] liberal
that deals with emotions notice that
we're we're four minutes into his
voicemails now and there's still been no
substantive argument made about any of
my criticisms of what trump said at the
rally you can't deal with facts and
why are you liberal so afraid of donald
trump
why is he being censored all over what's
the deal anyway so then he called back a
third time and we're not we can't listen
to 10 minutes of this stuff but
here's a uh this is a message for dave
david now he's screaming over something
in the background parkman the [ __ ]
parker you know it's amazing i'm trying
to watch the trump rally and you got
your big [ __ ] mouth
going and your comments
and you don't even know what the [ __ ]
you're talking about so he is getting
increasingly agitated with each success
successive voicemail he's more at marps
at you are
you are a [ __ ] the reason why this
isn't
broadcast on other adverts uh other
networks is because of the censorship
with your
your um
supporters big tech and uh anybody know
what he's talking about i have no idea
anyway so that's a new caller he's
completely belligerent completely and
totally belligerent really really just
kind of unbelievable i want to say thank
you to
multibeast who is now a 23 month twitch
subscriber and is number two today uh
this is uh this hearing scheduled to
start at the top of the hour we'll be
running it all day i'm gonna be in and
out because we've got a very busy day
here we are in production and producing
different elements of different things i
want to say thank you to cody turner
cody is today's
first ever user of the new coupon code
fix the court cody you have won yourself
a free item
at uh davidpakman.com
gear please email in
let us know what you would like
jack says david sir i'm phone banking
tonight for john fetterman encourage
others to sign up primary in less than
two months nicely done jack
nicely done now i hope you don't need
any machines to phone bank we're doing a
class action lawsuit against all
machines yeah tucker freestone says new
caller almost sounds like pillow i agree
i agree very very much
um that is absolutely true
absolutely true
um couple other things here here's video
of uh so this was described as video of
ted cruz accosting an airline employee
he seems kind of calm in this video but
i guess the cops were called on ted cruz
at an airport let's listen
i guess the context is ted cruz is in
bozeman montana in this video and he
like missed his flight
[Music]
i mean in this video he doesn't seem to
be accosting anyone
is an officer yeah but okay anyway so i
don't know the full scope of that
um here is stained lead singer aaron
lewis now i actually had some run-ins
with the stand guys because they're a
band from western massachusetts from
where i grew up and as when i famously
worked at circuit city selling extended
service plans the guys from stained
would often come in
and i never had any notable experience
whatsoever other than they bought like
they bought machines of different kinds
we're doing a class action lawsuit
against all machines
anyway he apparently has gone off the
deep end politically and it happened a
long time ago and it's really a shame
you know as [ __ ] up as it sounds
maybe we should listen to what vladimir
putin is saying
oh
maybe just maybe
when klaus schwab
and george soros uh oh here we go
when the old jewish men are on the same
page
and every other
dirty [ __ ] earth destroying
[ __ ] all jumps on the same
bandwagon
he just gave a list of jews who are
dirty
maybe just maybe we should [ __ ] take
a good look at that
why are they trying to protect ukraine
so much
what do they all have to lose
it's quite a crowd huh quite a crowd at
these events smoking indoors i mean it's
all it's all crazy what's happening
have here have you seen the pictures
with wooden guns
and
and all the bodies and body bags laying
in the background and all of a sudden
one of the bodies starts moving and
[ __ ] sits up and fixes his [ __ ]
body bag
well while the
while the the
the person that's that's the reporter is
reporting
people if you haven't seen that you
better start [ __ ] looking elsewhere
[Applause]
[Music]
if you haven't seen
vladimir putin actually say
that he's
fighting the deep state right now okay
so very very sick and unfortunately this
has been going on for a while with aaron
lewis it's it's it's really disturbing
it's it's completely bonked i know it's
completely insane i want to say thank
you to tim
white
who is a new member at
joinpakman.com is new member number four
today
thank you so much sir very much
appreciate that
uh we are standing by here for the first
day of hearings for joe biden's first of
unknown number of supreme court nominees
today we'll be opening statements from
both the nominee as well as uh the chair
and vice chair of the committees and all
committee members tomorrow they are go
oh hold on a second
um
the person who just called me pak joo is
banned hope it was worth it sir uh
you're gone one
only comment ever on my channel got you
banned never to be heard from again
um
tomorrow there tomorrow it starts at 9am
and there will be actual back and forth
questioning
and uh should be it should be quite
interesting should be quite interesting
let me see what else i have i i really
do have a lot of different things here
um
oh
there was like a physical altercation so
this is
this is the um
okay i i believe this is the ohio senate
race where this guy josh mandel is
running and i believe this is the exact
same correct me if i'm wrong guys isn't
jd vance running in this exact race as
well
do i have that correct it's just a who's
who of deplorables
um i believe that that's it so two of
the people during the debate got in each
other's face and it's just like guys
you're what none of you we should vote
for none of you look at this
no you don't i do you've never been in
the private sector
[Music]
when the candidates need to be separated
from each other at a debate you know
something's gone very very wrong
these people are just pathetic
watch what happens just wild threats
just completely wild everybody's
completely out of control
um
it's really a shame though that the
democrats are no longer civil
uh let's see thank you to lord le brand
for the twitch prime subscription now up
to six months welcome lord
sir
i think uh an appropriate name in that
in that example
um
see what else we've got here oh here's
steve bannon
now
really looking like b arthur i mean it's
it's very very strange what's going on
with steve bannon here he is
again
saying we are just we're just on the
verge of decertifying the election and
it's like steve no we're not there's no
there's not even such a process there's
no process for decertification it
doesn't exist check it out
of these electors and that's what
remember let's get our language very
specific
we're not asking and we've never asked
for president trump's never asked for
this movement's never asked for it to
change the election and to flip it to
donald j trump that is just not the
right nomenclature it's not the right
language
what we've asked for is very similar
that only certifiable
constitutional legal chain of custody
votes from american citizens can be
counted for the november 2020 election
and there's no evidence anything but
that was what what would count what
counted for a nearly two year old
election at this point once they're
counted right in an accurate way
and real votes not things that came with
their machines although i'm not a
machine oh we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines steve
bannon's clothes washer in disarray no
but once we get everything counted
okay that's the election and we know now
whether it is in pennsylvania whether it
is in uh whether it's in wisconsin
arizona or georgia those four states
alone
we understand right now and i think
eventually nevada and michigan but those
four states alone we can move guys it
sounds like trump had 400 electoral
votes right now the state legislature to
decertify to decertify the electors
there's no such thing not to flip the
election to decertify the electors and
do what the constitution says flip it to
the house of representatives where you
vote by uh you vote by delegation state
by state and of course we control what
26 or 27 of those delegations are
controlled it in 20 i think it's 26 23
to 1. completely delusional be arthur
steve bannon delivering an another one
of these
uh rants
um mck says and we will ban machines
here is senator dianne feinstein heading
towards the hearing which will start
uh momentarily
thanks to gravy j there is looney
lindsey graham
certain to deliver a principled and
defiant speech about something he
misheard
thanks to gravy j
new member number six today we do have a
new coupon code fix the court we must
fix the court there is um uh
well i could i could say a lot of things
about josh hawley i'm not going to say
them but that is josh hawley it looks
like lindsay has some kind of orthopedic
seat bottom at his chair uh which he
doesn't like he asked for that to be
removed and it was indeed taken away
please take take this away
uh lindsay did not like that he does not
want any kind of strange cushions
on his seat um do i have other
voicemails
um
something from the eggman
hey dave zelinski is calling on israel
to help them out over there you know
saying like quote holocaust stuff
holocaust this how can you let this
happen to a jewish holocaust geez eggman
you're off today huh run country but you
know
um i said this weeks ago that israel
should help them out should i be
president of a country shallow i would
vote for the egg man yeah
i mean i think i don't know what the
rules are on convicted felons running
for president i say that with total
peace and love the eggman's not been you
know not kept that secret
but i would i would support the eggman
thanks to fubs for the twitch prime
subscription your new member number
seven today seven
um let's see what else we've got here
from the standpoint of voicemails as we
stand by here's one from whitney also
about jewish people
it's funny how i see all these tears
from the jewish community when
like
mexico's babies are being taken away
and
you know
dalton says david sir like the
pennsylvania election results steve
bannon is certifiable well said very
very much well said i think that that's
that's absolutely right
uh how long is this expected to go today
i don't know
i don't know
um
some number of hours i would say uh
here's marjorie taylor greene lying
about tick tocks
and what is the white house doing as the
world slides dangerously close to
devastating world war
paying off tick-tock influencers now
remember that the tick-tock influencers
that the white house met with were not
paid
now you could say well the white house
shouldn't talk to tick-tock people or
they should talk to tick-tock people or
whatever but they weren't paid lie for
them more concerned with favorable
headlines from the washington post and
the new york times than avoiding world
war
more concerned with social media likes
than protecting american jobs and
families
and what yeah so anyway nobody would
know the tick tock people were not paid
for anything
um so i don't i don't know you know
maybe in russia tick tockers are paid
there is i believe that that's marcia
blackburn can anybody confirm senator
marshall blackburn from tennessee that
said they don't say tennessee it's
tennessee down there
which is fine which is fine they can say
it however they want
um
let me see what else i've got here as we
wait
um
what else do i have here
there is the nominee a judge kitanji
brown jackson approaching the hearing
room uh looks like that's dick durbin
to our right behind the woman in the
black shirt is that dick durbin i think
so
um
and a number of different people
uh and chuck grassley to our left
chuck grassley
not exactly an individual who's had a
positive impact on american politics i
think we can say i want to say thank you
to burner account number three as well
as jen here for the two twitch prime
subscriptions thank you very much
i appreciate that very very seriously
um and we have uh
a bunch of different video coming in
um the start will be opening statements
opening statements and judge katanji
brown jackson will get to make an
opening statement herself as well
expecting that to be very very
interesting uh i don't let me know in
the chat or in a super chat
what do you expect to be the main line
of attack
and disparagement of uh judge jackson
what i've read is that it's going to be
that she's soft on child porn i've read
that that's going to be their primary
means of attack and there's actually a
whole you know
we've talked before about how
lower courts often are constrained when
it comes to something like child porn by
the letter of the law there was this
famous story from new york about how
technically the way the law was written
if you didn't right click save as you
didn't really possess the porn and it
led to the the law being changed in new
york it's a big story that we covered so
it'll be interesting to see if they they
go with that approach um i don't know if
there will be questions about her lsat
score that's another one that that's
been uh bandied about to some degree
uh so we will see we will see
there is the nominee amy klobuchar
saying hello and uh to her to now is
richard senator richard blumenthal as
you can see
this is chris coons here over on the
left and chuck grassley a republican as
you can see everybody's saying hello
i hope i'm not misidentifying any of
these people
this is just a photographer here on the
left so i don't know who that is thanks
to weslow for the twitch prime
subscription you're number 10 today very
much appreciate that and if you are just
joining us um because of this important
momentous occasion our coupon code today
is fix the court which provides you with
an ungodly discount on my website
joinpakman.com
chuck grassley still doing seat duty um
holding the chair to to very very
uh demurely and uh respectfully push it
in
when uh judge jackson ultimately sits
down
a lot of pomp and circumstance taking
place here as is often the case
uh and we are watching all of it
he is very very strong now if the ch i
don't know if a chair is considered a
machine we're doing a class action
lawsuit against all machines if so it
may be pulled out from under her
literally and metaphorically
um
at some point during the hearings which
would be a really really
uh crazy thing
she is not expected to announce the
banning of any genders however and we
will ban men that is not expected to be
part of this hearing from everything
i've read you guys tell me if you've
heard otherwise
but i have not
heard anything about that
let's listen brown jackson to sit on the
united states supreme court this
committee has 22 members evenly split
between democrats and republicans
here we go your committee will come to
order the committee will begin its
consideration the nomination of judge
katanji
to be the 116th justice of oh my god the
audio welcome judge jackson
and
to you and your family thank you senator
this is a moment
all right let's try going elsewhere for
the audio
of events and the ground rules for the
hearing
oh it's cutting out everywhere
statement we'll go and see
switching between democratic oh my god
senators
who made their opening statements we'll
hear from judge thomas griffith
professor lisa fairfax who are here
today to introduce
what on earth we'll have five minutes to
make an opening statement finally we'll
administer the oath jackson and she will
make
that will continue this audio guys i
mean this is it's on every feed
for those sitting in the audience
welcome
could be here to witness this historic
occasion i ask
to be respectful and quiet during the
hearing dear god stand up unless you're
entering or exiting the room
be asked by
one of our distinguished members of the
capitol the audio is on the feed guys
because it's on this feed as well
for those sitting in the audience
welcome i think antripha might be
controlling the audio
i ask
i'll look for another feedback quiet
during the hearing it's the master feed
stand up unless you're entering or
exiting the room unbelievable
be asked by
one of our distinguished members by
one of our industries sit down if you
refuse you'll be escorted
let's try nbc i mean this is this is
crazy
it's on everything to be clear it's on
every feed tolerate any
audience any disruption will result in
immediate room c-span has the audio as
well all right so hopefully they'll fix
it at some point
judge jackson as i said
again for being here today with your
family and
this is unbelievable the court has a
long and storied history
have been filled by many superb justices
whose contribution
the rule of law have stood the test of
time
but the
the reality is that the court's members
in one respect
have never
really reflected the nation they served
when the supreme court met for the very
first time
i have seventeen having some audio
issues with the feed here which we are
working out we will get that to you
it's not a washington post issue is the
thing it's it's on every feed of nearly
4 million
neither african americans nor
right to vote
there was no equal justice
for a majority of people living in
america
it's more than 230 years the supreme
court has had
justices
108 have been white men
these two
justices have been men of color only
have served on the court and just won a
woman of color
justice has been a black woman
you judge
can be the first
it's not easy being the first
often you have to be the best
in some ways the bravest
you're not prepared to face that kind of
heat that kind of scrutiny that
air of the national spotlight but your
presence here today
is to brave this process will give
inspiration to millions of
who see themselves in you if you're just
joining us the audio problem is on the
feed subtitles are on but they are not
being transmitted
young african-american women
they're
seeing your pursuit as people will go to
pbs which has working subtitles at least
your guiding
found in your life and in your work that
the constitutional
americans not just the wealthy and
powerful the judge
favoritism and that the judiciary must
live up
unbearable above the entrance equal
justice under
so today's proud day for america we've
come along
1790 and we know that we still have
to form a more perfect union
it's a moment reminds me of this
and are incredible oh these people don't
know what the hell they're doing
ruth bader ginsburg at her
hearing
he said you face you
harsher judge than this committee
and that is the
and that judgment is likely to revolve
around the question
did she restrict freedom or did she
expand it
statement time and again because it asks
a vital question
street judge us
judge jackson
will remember you as a justice who never
stop working to defend
but i also ask the members of this
committee as
landmark confirmation process
to consider how
each senator as we face our
constitutional
advising consent
this moment also
i think president barack obama another
trailblazer said
illinoisian with the late justice john
paul stevenson
president obama said while we cannot
replace
experience or wisdom i will seek someone
with seminar similar guys again if
you're just joining us the audio feed is
on every feed c-span's dealing with it
everybody's dealing with it it's not on
i it's i've not done anything to you
okay please don't attack me it's just
the feed that's what it is that replace
justice breyer
but with you
we have a nominee who embodies the same
qualities
your record
it's an integrity from the championship
debate team throw them the hell out of
here senior high school
to harvard and harvard
to your three judicial clerkships your
work is a
defender a lawyer in private practice a
member
mission a federal district judge and
circuit court judge
about your career you've been a champion
for the rule of law to
fight even at the risk of public
criticism
at the
state sentencing commission a bipartisan
group which reflects
of american thinking on law enforcement
you set up
the truly represented congressional
intent when it came to
criminal sentencing fairer
and you did it by fight as we listen to
senator durbin a note we are hearing the
same audio blip that you are we are told
the senate is trying to fix that and we
hope they do shortly for example
the commission implementing act a law
that i negotiated with
jeff sessions that reduced the infamous
hundred to one crack powder sentencing
disparity
and you joined every one of them they
got it to make that change to the
sentencing guidelines retroactive
you gave a powerful speech and i'm going
to quote it you said there is no excuse
for insisting that those who are serving
excessive sentences under the long
disputed and now discredited prior
guideline must carry on as though none
of this has happened
the vote in favor of retroactivity was
unanimous on the commission republicans
and democrats shared your deal lindsey
graham fixed it and you've gone to great
lengths to explain how the law affects
real people
indeed with your nomination we can be
confident that the court its role and
its decisions will be more
understandable to the american public in
your time on the bench you've taken the
time to explain your decisions and their
consequences
when you're before this committee just
last year for your dc circuit hearing
you described how you quote take extra
care to communicate with parties you
added and i quote i speak to them
directly and not just to their lawyers i
use their names i explain every stage of
the proceeding because i want them to
know what's going on
as a result of that approach you've made
the law more approachable to litigants
and american people
the cameras and the lights here today
can make it easy to forget that at its
core the responsibility you seek is one
of service and i'm fully confident
you'll serve americans from all walks of
life all backgrounds fairly and
faithfully
now there may be some who claim
without a shred of evidence that you'll
be a rubber stamp for this president
for these would-be critics i have four
words
look at the record
your complete record has been scoured by
this committee on four different
occasions
all of your nearly 600 written opinions
read and re-read 12 000 pages of
transcripts meeting minutes and other
materials for the sentencing commission
your sworn testimony before the
committee less than a year ago
every published and reported word you've
written or spoken your detailed answers
to lengthy questions for those who say
they need more i would answer that you
have sat down personally with every
member on this diocese of the committee
democrats and republicans
a fair review of all of this makes clear
your values and your guiding principles
you have ruled for and against
presidents and administrations of both
parties
you've ruled for prosecutors and for
defendants
you've ruled for workers and for their
employers and you've been faithful to
the law not to any person or political
cause
now there may be others who allege that
you're before us today as a product of
the campaign of dark money groups
once again your record in the process
that led to this nomination believe that
claim
to suggest that you're here merely
because an organization supports you
ignores your qualifications and the
broad range of support you bring to this
in selecting you as his nominee
president biden
undertook a transparent selection
process he sought the input of senators
from both parties senator grassley and i
met in the oval room with the president
he invited us to proffer any nominees
that we care to do at the end of the day
the president alone chose you
he's put his faith in you to deliver
justice to the highest level the court i
share that faith
in announcing your nomination the
president spoke to many reasons that you
deserve to sit on the high court
he noted the perspective you'll bring as
a former member of the sentencing
commission as the first justice since
thurgood marshall with considerable
criminal defense experience and is the
only the second current justice only the
second
to serve as a federal trial court judge
he also noted your upbringing in the
fact that you come from a law
enforcement family
yet despite that shared family
experience despite your record we've
heard claims that you're quote soft on
crime these baseless charges are unfair
a conservative national review columnist
called claims brought by one of my
colleagues quote meritless to the point
of demagoguery
they fly in the face of pledges my
colleagues made that they would approach
your nomination with civility and
respect
and fact checkers including the
washington post abc news and cnn have
exposed some of these charges as
falsehoods
critics have even stooped to accusing
you of sharing the views of the clients
you represented even though they know
that your work as an attorney was in
service to the bill of rights and the
constitution's promise of effective
assistance council
would law enforcement officials and
organizations including the
international association of chiefs of
police
the national organization of black law
enforcement executives and the fraternal
order of police have endorsed your
nomination if you were soft on crime of
course not
i'm confident the american people will
see through these attacks and any other
last-minute attempts to derail your
confirmation
in closing i want to share the words of
one more illinois if you my if you bear
with me a rather famous one named
abraham lincoln
in august 1864
at the height of the civil war
president lincoln addressed the 166th
ohio regiment
lincoln said to the soldiers and i quote
i happened temporarily to occupy this
big white house
i am living witness that one of your
children may look to come here as my
father's child has
judge jackson we are all just temporary
occupants of the senate the house
even with a lifetime appointment to the
highest court in the land
you judge jackson are one of mr
lincoln's living witnesses of an america
that is unafraid of challenge
willing to risk change
confident of the basic goodness of our
citizens
and your living witness to the fact that
in america all is possible
i now recognize my colleague and friend
the ranking member senator grassley
judge jackson congratulations welcome to
you and your family
i thank you for taking time to visit
with me in my office after the president
nominated you
since president biden announced his
nominee for the supreme court
i've been encouraging my colleagues to
schedule meetings with you judge jackson
and they have come off
in addition i've continually emphasized
the need for a thorough
respectful
process by the committee grassley is a
horrible person for people who are
wondering yeah no he's his record is
just vile
from this hearing
and what they shouldn't expect at the
hearing
we will conduct a thorough exhaustive
examination
of judge jackson's record and views
we won't try to turn this into a
spectacle based upon alleged
process fouls
good news on that front
we're off to a very good start
unlike the start to the kavanagh
hearings
uh we
don't want to have repeated
choreographed interruptions we also
don't have widespread allegations of
sexual assault like democrats
interrupted me for more than an hour
during my oh my god on the cavanaugh
here what a loser what we will do
however
is ask tough questions about judge
jackson's
judicial philosophy
in any supreme court nomination
the most important thing that i look for
is the nominee's view of the law
judicial philosophy and view on the role
of a judge in our constitutional system
i'll be looking to see whether judge
jackson is committed to the constitution
as originally understood
we all know there's a difference of
opinion about the role judges should
play
some of us believe the judges are
supposed to interpret the law as it was
understood when written
not make new law or simply fill in
vacuum
those of us who share that view
think that under our constitution
congress and not the federal courts
are given the authority to make law and
to set policy
now there are others who believe that
the courts should make policy they
believe in a so-called living
constitution they think that the
constitution's text and structure don't
limit what a judge can do
to them deciding what the constitution
means is really a quote-unquote value
judgment
under that approach
judges can exercise their own
independent value judgments
one of the leading advocates for this
approach explained that as a judge you
quote
reach the answer that essentially your
values tell you to reach end of quote
in other words
those who subscribe to this philosophy
think that the founders really meant to
hide
elephants in mouse holes then
with a bit of creativity
these judges can always find
that elephant
that sounds like a good job description
instead
for legislators and not for judges
but for at least
four years democrats
systematically voted against many
well-credentialed
nominees
that were diverse professionally
diverse geographically as have
republicans against democratic
nominations
diverse ethnically
was it racist
or anti-women for them to do so did he
just say was it racist
democrats did it because the nominees
didn't agree with living
constitutionalism just as republicans
have opposed nominees based upon
their judicial philosophy
there are lots of problems with living
constitutionalism
in the senate
we spend a lot of time
writing legislation
we argue over the language
we negotiate over how broad or narrow
certain provisions of laws should be
if
we can't convince our colleagues to
adopt all of our ideas
we have been known to compromise every
once in a while
we depend on judges to interpret laws as
we write them if judges impose their own
policy preferences from the bench and
essentially revise the laws we pass
it makes it harder for us to write good
laws sometimes we need to include a
provision that's very broad to get a
colleague's support
if a judge rewrites the law later
because of vague notions about fairness
or equity or common good
that unravels all of our work here in
the congress
more importantly
the american people should be able to
read the law
and know what it means
they shouldn't have to ask how a federal
judge who disagrees with law
could reinterpret the words on that page
all of this leads
to the conclusion as to why
we must carefully examine federal judges
records especially supreme court
nominees
judge jackson has served as an assistant
public defender worked in private
practice and served on the united states
sentencing commission
she also served as a federal district
court judge from 2013 to 2021
she served on the d.c circuit
since june
last year
i'm sure senators will have a few
questions for judge jackson about the
two opinions she's authored since
joining the d.c circuit
as for a district court record there
have been some accusations that we
cherry pick
some of judge jackson's criminal cases
well don't worry we're going to talk
about other cases as well
i was disappointed that we weren't able
to get bipartisan agreement
to ask for judge jackson's documents
from her time as vice chair of the
sentencing commission the commission is
an independent agency created to advise
and assist congress and the executive
branch in the development of effective
and efficient
crime policy and that's a quote
unfortunately it sounds like we'll have
to wait until those documents are
required to be released and that will be
about 20 years from now
democrats
have argued for time
democrats have argued that judge
jackson's time on the commission is an
important part of her experience that
she'll draw on as a judge
the democrats are right on that point
that's why it would have been good to
see what our views were
as the head of the commission
uh
explained in a letter to senator durbin
the public doctrines turned over to this
committee represent the case it's a
pretty bonkers opening statement guys
and not necessarily judge jackson's own
views the obama white house sent us
roughly
68 000 pages of material not enough but
more than 38
000 of the 68 000 pages
are repeated
copies
of emails threads that
keep the track
keeping track of the tweets about the
garland nomination
those here god contained just one tweet
about judge jackson
more than 13 000 of the 68 thousand
pages are just lists of previous
nominations
so that leaves only 16 000. guys they
only have 16 000 real pages to go
through house that aren't obviously
useless like all the other documents
received right but for comparison the
white house has still
withheld 48 000 pages under the
presidential records
uh and foia exemptions now that's a lot
of hiding
but the limited number of useful
i didn't expect this to get insane until
tomorrow
white house i was wrong show exactly why
the sentencing commission documents
would have been important
there are a number of dark money groups
on the left that argue federal judges
should make policy decisions based on
judges own values i've talked about the
troubling role of far left dark money
groups like demand justice have played
in this administration will he mention
soros
process he would
the demand justice isn't creating short
lists for president biden to pick
judicial nominees from or putting out
new litmus tests they're running ads
campaign this is vile
campaigns attacking the independence of
the jews these are just personal
grievances like this has nothing to do
really with her the nomination process
progressive prosecutors who are soft on
violent crime in the face of rising
crime waves in cities like san francisco
philadelphia boston and new los angeles
now
what does that have to do with the
nominee before us i would love to know
the obama white house records indicate
that a co-founder of the demand justice
played an important role in judge
jackson's nomination to the sentencing
commission and the district court the
demand justice co-founder even
interviewed judge jackson about the
nomination to the sentencing commit
commission it would be helpful to know
what demand justice co-founder learned
from that process and why they strongly
support judge jackson
however it isn't all been bad on the
document front i want to make clear
we'd ask for briefs that aren't
available online for dc circuit cases
judge jackson worked on as an attorney
at first we were told they might not be
available for a few weeks
to but to our present surpr pleasant
surprise we received them early this is
incoherence the white house had asked
for the documents as well
judging by timetable
we were originally given to get the
breeze that request was made after she
was announced
now those documents the bar continues to
be lowered like i expected incoherent
questioning tomorrow i didn't think just
the ranking member's opening statement
would be so delusional and deranged
qualifying nominees who have represented
criminal defendants
that's
just not the case and i think that's a
very unfair accusation previously
supreme court nominees have also
represented criminal defendants on
appeals chief justice roger roberts was
appointed by supreme court to represent
a defendant in an important criminal
law case and he also helped represent an
inmoi inmate in a florida
death row
and justice barrett represented a
criminal defendant appealing their
conviction while she was in private
practice now i've distinguished between
two types of nominees who have worked in
criminal cases there are bill of rights
attorneys who want to protect defendants
constitutional rights
then there are what i've called criminal
defense lawyers who disagree with our
criminal laws
they want to undermine laws that they
have policy disagreements with
and of course that's a very important
difference right just a year ago
no maybe it's now two years ago
democrats had like a book report when
you've not read the book he's based on
arguments these nominees made on behalf
of clients i can read off quotes of
democrats please don't to trump nominees
but we only have
a few minutes for these opening
statements thank god i'd run out of time
on a final note
during
justice barrett's confirmation hearing
democrats said that she would quote
unquote
judicial torpedo aiming at protecting
protections for pre-existing conditions
we heard that argument repeatedly
conservatives and anyone who
actually looked at her record and laws
said that that was strictly nonsense
but democrats were sure otherwise
well when that case was finally decided
democrats were proven wrong
i'm sure that won't deter any of my
democrat colleagues for making some
confident predictions this time around
as well but the public record
this is crazy
their track record and perhaps take
those claims
with a grain of salt they were wrong
in their strong declarations how justice
barrett would rule
judge jackson congratulations on your
nomination all of that being said
congratulations
about your record your views on the law
and your judicial philosophy thank you
thank senator next is the president pro
tem of the senate and former chairman of
the committee patrick leahy
well thank you mr chair and i
judge jackson welcome is is really good
to see you again you know uh today and
actually throughout this week the
committee and the country
are going to hear from
judge
jackson she's been nominated to be the
next associate justice of the united
states supreme court
any nomination any nomination of the
court is historic
they've only been 115 justices in our
nation's history
judge jackson's nomination of course is
historic
in more ways than one
her nomination
pending a confirmation by the senate
will bring us one step closer to having
a supreme court that is more reflective
of our nation
when the diversity of race and gender
background education
and experience allow all americans
to look to their court
and see in its justices a reflection of
the american people
judge jackson you know with your
presence here today
you are writing a new page in the
history of america
a good page
who the president nominates and the
senate decides to confirm to our federal
judiciary
and especially our nation's highest
court that's extremely important
the american people
our constituents
and their faith
and their faith in the courts
that's central to our democracy
they lose their faith
then democracy loses
the decisions being our courts and
ultimately in the supreme court affect
the deadly lives of each one of us
fundamental questions about for example
access to health care
the integrity of our elections the
fairness of our criminal justice system
the preservation of bedrock
environmental laws
protections for workers
these issues
and many more are routinely decided by
the court
every american must believe that the
court is going to be impartial
they must believe that our courts are
not a mere political arm of the
executive or the congress
but faithful only to the rule of law
the stakes and democracy are simply too
high
let's make a few things clear
judge jackson is no
judicial activist
she is not a puppet of the so-called
radical left
she's been praised by republican
appointed
judges for jurisprudence
lawyers from the right and the left
who appeared before her in court have
called her judicious and even-handed
before as in the senate i tried a lot of
cases in
trial court and then courts of appeal
that's what i wanted somebody who was
judicious and even-handed i didn't care
what their politics were
yeah it'll be interesting to see you
know lindsey graham was a strong
supporter of judge jackson at the lower
court confirmation he's sitting there on
the left of your screen now it'll be
interesting to see whether he sings a
completely different tune about the very
same person he seemed to love not long
ago
and no
she's not soft on crime
her background as a federal public
defender would bring an informed
perspective of our criminal justice
system to the supreme court
i'm proud of being a former prosecutor
but confidence in my prosecution of a
case
was strongest when i knew the defendant
had the best possible representation
when both sides and the presiding judge
have a real grasp of our
criminal justice system
that's when justice is most likely to be
done
so i would say that judge jackson's
background
is not a liability to the court
it's a much needed asset to the court
and since her nomination again here
today we've heard about the
long distinguished record of judge
jackson
graduate of harvard harvard law school
a judicial clerk at the district circuit
and supreme court
level
a federal appellate judge a federal
district court judge a member of the u.s
sentencing commission an attorney in
private practice
and a federal public defender
what a resume
all these experiences
and perspectives
have provided her a mastery
of our justice system
and i'd say in particular the criminal
justice system
if she
is confirmed
she'd become the first ever justice
to have served as a federal public
defender
that's an important experience given how
much the court shapes our criminal
justice system interesting
i say that from my experience as
a senator but also my experience
for nearly a decade as a prosecutor
and perhaps most of all it is judge
jackson's nearly 10 years
as an appellate and trial judge to
underscore the experience
she'd bring to the supreme court
she was confirmed unanimously by the
senate in 2013 to the d.c circuit court
she served with distinction for eight
years she issued more than 500 opinions
she presided over a dozen trials
and a bipartisan majority of the senate
confirmed her to the d.c circuit court
of appeals last
year let's be honest she's a fair
and impartial jurors
with a fidelity to the law of course we
need to do this right but the hearings
could be as follows
did we put kavanaugh on the court we did
okay you're in judge jackson that's it
the hearing's over america is feeling
like our courts have become
increasingly partisan
the extreme interests of pressure groups
on both sides of the political spectrum
they've left the american people
wondering if they can get a fair shake
in our courts
and yet in this moment we have before
a unique opportunity to change that
narrative
under no illusion
that we can mend this process overnight
but we have before the nominee
who's brought us together across party
lines before
and one i hope we can bring us back
together again
the senate can change course
return to how we fairly and objectively
evaluate nominees
we can do that with a highly qualified
nominee we have in judge jackson
now as chair durbin said
i'm the president pro tempore of the
senate
i'm a former chairman of this committee
i've participated in 20 prior supreme
court nomination processes
mostly into
confirmation a small handful not
in fact the first
justice signing motorhomes from your
state
senator durbin john paul stevens
i've supported nominees from both
democratic and republican presidents
and judge jackson i found a
distinguished nominee with an
unassailable record
that merits our respect regardless of
party i believe the american people
seeing her what i've come to learn in my
review of her career and her life story
her nomination is a reflection of the
arc of our democracy
the act of bends towards justice as dr
king once said
although in fits and starts with every
generation
we have sought to become more inclusive
more representative
we've looked at citizens civic leaders
elected representatives interesting note
of trivia the average age of the
senators who have spoken so far is 82 82
that's average
my diversity
judge jackson's story her nomination
today is part of the evolving story of
america
so judge jackson i want to congratulate
you on this nomination
despite all the darkness in the world
and the political
brinksmanship has unfortunately become a
hallmark of congress in recent years
your nomination actually fills me with
hope
hope for the court hope for the rule of
law hope for the country
one need looked no further
than the chaos the devastation
and the humanity in humanity halfway
around the world in ukraine
to know how precious our democracy is
and how precious the legacy we have at
our independent federal judiciary
i need to look no further than my own
grandchildren
all of them
to know how necessary our fight for
freedom
fairness inequality is
the independence and impartiality of our
courts under the supreme court
our cornerstone the great experiment
there's the united states and you the
american people have a nominee in whom
they can be proud we have before as an
historic moment and i hope we can meet
it as senators so i look forward to your
testimony thank you thank you senator
please sit next to another former chair
of the committee and senator from south
carolina lindsey graham here's lindsey
thank you mr chairman um
again congratulations well-deserved
honor here
you have worked hard all your life and
yeah yeah must be proud of
i have said
in the past that i think it's good for
the
court to look like america so count men
on the idea of making the court more
diverse
and in the history of our country we've
never had an african-american woman
serve on the court
but i also said i didn't get much
coverage i want
i want i want the court
to play a particular role in america
one is make it more look like the
country but also make it operate in the
confines of the constitution that didn't
didn't get a lot of coverage
so the hearings are going to be
challenging
for you
informative for the public and
respectful by us i hope we can meet that
those criteria um it won't be a circus
we're off to a good start we'll see uh
chairman grassley couldn't get first
word out of his mouth
before they shut down the place so
that's
off to a good start
most of us couldn't go back to our
offices during kavanaugh without getting
spit on hope that doesn't happen to
y'all
i don't think it will
uh as to the historic nature of your
appointment i understand but when i get
lectured about this from my democratic
colleagues
i remember janice rogers brown
african-american woman that was
filibustered by the same people praising
you
i remember remember miguel estrada one
of the finest people i ever met he's
winding up
completely wiped out
didn't make it through the uh
uh gang of uh
14 whatever gang i was in i've been in
so many i can't remember
he he didn't make the cut
well-lived life just completely ruined
so if you're hispanic or
african-american conservative it's about
your philosophy
oh boy now it's going to be about the
historic nature of here we go
it's going to be about your philosophy
the bottom line here is when it is about
philosophy when it's somebody of color
on our side
it's about we're all racist if we ask
hard questions it's not gonna fly with
us we're used to it by now at least i am
so it's not gonna matter a bit to any of
us we're gonna ask you what we think you
need to be asked and senator hawley you
need to ask her about her record as a
district court judge you should i hope
you do and we'll see what she says very
fair game
uh now
president biden had a choice here
and he has every right to make it
elections have consequences he had many
qualified african-american women to
choose from he chose you
michelle chiles a district court judge
from south carolina supported by jim
clyburn that was in the mix i think it
came down to about two three four people
don't know for sure but that's what the
press was reporting
and uh when it came to judge
charles uh
this arabella group senator whitehouse
you talk about dark money you may be
onto something
this arabella group is funded by source
and some other liberal being there
they've got so many groups in their
group i can't name them all now but they
basically said if you if you pick childs
you may have a primary opponent
the fl cio said justice judge child was
a union buster
interesting to talk about people who
weren't nominated
was really pretty vicious to be honest
with you
so you say uh
did you guys know ted nugent could have
been chosen as the nominee he wasn't he
wasn't on the left believes you do
or they wouldn't have spent the money
they spent to have you in this chair
so we're going to find out how that
statement
holds up over time
a viewer's guide to this hearing
she will be asked about her sentencing
practices as a
district court judge and she'll have a
chance to explain her reasoning and you
can make up for yourself what this means
but it's good to be asked
uh
about our legal views i'll ask her about
the law of armed conflict and her view
of the law of armed conflict the fact
that you represented gitmo detainees is
not a problem with me everybody deserves
a lawyer you're doing their country a
great service when you defend the most
unpopular people but i do want to know
about your amicus briefs after you're no
longer a defense counsel weighing into
the supreme court about how they decide
law of war issues that matters a lot to
me
i think it does matter that the groups
that came to your aid at the expense of
judge childs how did that happen and why
were they doing what they were doing
what is it about your nomination that
the most liberal people on the umbrella
of arabella threw in their money their
time their support and threatened
threaten
joe biden if he picked
judge childs i want to know more about
that
i want to know about your judicial
philosophy
because people on the left the far
extreme
part of the left
believe that you were kind of an
interesting note card system he's got
they
reached that conclusion maybe there's
no explanation you can give us but let
we'll we'll talk about that
now when we say this is not cavanaugh
what do we mean well we mean she hasn't
been accused of sexual assault by
multiple people however the windows
busted by groups that's what it means
it means that no republican senator
is going to unleash on you and attack
about your character when the hearing is
virtually over
none of us i hope have been sitting on
information
about you as a person
for weeks or months
you come into our offices and we never
share it with you to allow you to give
your side the story we wait to the very
last minute when the hearing's about to
be gavel concluded and say oh by the way
i've got this letter
and so happened that every media outlet
in the country had the letter too so the
next morning there were headlines all
over the country really accusing judge
kavanaugh being basically bill cosby
none of us are going to do that to you
and if any of us does that to you
all hell will break out
and it should
the media will uh be your biggest
cheerleader
they're in your camp they have every
right to pick who they want to pick
they won't be this constant attack
on you like judge cavanaugh and other
conservative judiciaries this is
complete and total gaslighting won't be
any questioning of where you go to
church
what kind of groups you're in in church
how you decide to raise your kids
what you believe in how you believe in
god
nobody's going to do that to you let's
wait and see and that's a good thing but
wait so you're the beneficiary of a lot
you're the beneficiary of republican
nominees having their life turned upside
down
and it didn't work
so i'm hoping that we can have a hearing
this respectful that's informative
that's challenging i mean that'll be up
to his colleagues
president biden has every right to pick
who he'd like to pick that comes with
winning the white house and i've been
very inclined to support the picks
of people that i would not have chosen
but this is a new game for the supreme
court
and this game is particularly disturbing
to me
because there's been a wholesale effort
wait what is it what's the new game that
she's a black woman what is he talking
about money from my state
and i don't like it very much
and if that's the way the game's going
to be played then
i'll have a response
and i don't expect it to be
reward that way of playing the game i
think he'll go nuts justice child judge
childs would have gotten 60 plus votes
there have been people in my caucus
easy to say we voted for her even though
we knew she would be a reliable liberal
vote
because i and senator scott would have
stepped up
now we're picked now we're facing a
choice
sponsored by the most radical elements
of the democratic party he already voted
for her in the last confirmation hearing
i have the most radical view
of what a judge should do
and you were their choice
and you'll be asked do you support
expanding the supreme court not up to
him i hope you give us an answer not up
to you it shouldn't be hard idiotic or
you don't
justice ginsburg said no
she thought if you just changed the
number of the court every time somebody
new came in power it would ruin the
court in the eyes of the public and make
it a joke over time i agree with that
so i hope you can give us an answer to
that question
because i think the court
would be better off
if the judges stood up
for the court
if the judges told politicians
don't play this game with the court
because over time nobody wins
so congratulations
it's going to be a couple interesting
days
and we're off to a better start than we
have been in the past unclear and the
one thing i can promise you you will not
be vilified you won't you will not be
attacked i don't know about the
religious views you will not be
accused of something
that you could not defend yourself
against until it was too late
thank you
thank you senator graham uh senator
feinstein
thanks very much all right guys we'll
keep this running i'm going to step away
briefly the hearings continue and we
will be watching all of it
congratulating you judge jackson on this
appointment
i've reviewed the records of a number of
judicial nominees during my service on
this committee this is actually the 10th
set of confirmation hearings for a
supreme court nominee that i've
participated in during my time in the
senate and looking at your record it's
clear that you have the qualifications
and the experience and the knowledge
needed to serve on the supreme court and
as a woman it makes me very proud of
that
as we begin these hearings we as
senators take seriously our
constitutional duty to advise the
president on his appointment of a new
supreme court justice
in the current term alone the supreme
court is addressing cases on issues that
are foundational to who we are as a
country let me just give you three
examples
the court is considering a woman's
fundamental right to control her own
body and make her own health care
decisions
it is considering the legal authority of
the environmental protection agency to
fight climate change and it's
considering whether states have the
power to enact common sense gun safety
protections
as a former mayor i saw how these
official how these problems
affect people everyday people on
everyday streets
throughout my city and then subsequently
the state of california
this is not your first time at this
in fact it's your fourth time in front
of this committee the full senate has
already confirmed you on a bipartisan
basis three times
to serve as vice chair of the u s
sentencing commission in 2010 as a
federal district court judge
2013 and as a federal appellate court
judge in
2021
and you have done us proud
each of the three times the senate has
considered your record
your experience and your ability
senators on both sides of the aisle have
determined that you have the
qualifications
and the temperament it takes to uphold
the values of our judicial branch
as i see it
those values are knowledge
even-handedness
impartiality
integrity respect for the rule of law
and fundamental fairness to all
and your record
actually shows that you exemplify these
values
the supreme court is not a political
institution
rather the court stands above politics
and above partisanship
and we look to federal judges to be
independent and unbiased
judge jackson in reviewing your record
one thing in particular stands out to me
and that's your commitment to uphold
justice under the law
this is one of the ultimate
responsibilities of the supreme court
and your record
suggests to me
that you understand the weight of that
responsibility
you've had several mentors early in your
career who unders who i understand were
important in instilling these values
in you as a young lawyer
one of these those mentors were justice
stephen breyer
who you served as a law clerk and to
whose seat on the supreme court you have
now been nominated what a treat for you
to see that happen and i know for him as
well
justice breyer has been a thoughtful and
even-handed judge throughout his career
so you have learned from the best
and you have brought those lessons
and that dedication to equal justice
with you throughout your career in the
law
you have strong credentials
you're a graduate of both harvard
university and harvard law school
a former supreme court clerk and you
have served as a federal judge for nine
years
most recently on the u.s court of
appeals for the district circuit
these are impressive credentials and
they are also familiar to those of us
who have received excuse me who have
reviewed
numerous nominees to the court
but you also bring experiences that are
less common especially at the supreme
court
the first is your service as a federal
public defender earlier in your career
if you were confirmed you would be the
first ever
federal public defender to sit on the
court
and the first justice since thurgood
marshall with significant experience
representing low-income defendants and
criminal cases
i believe this is very significant and
important
because as a former public defender you
understand the power of our
constitutional rights
including the sixth amendment right to
counsel and the fifth amendment right to
due process
you also understand the effect of law
and the law enforcement system on the
most vulnerable
and i believe your eight years of
expertise as a trial judge on the d.c
district court is very valuable
so
if confirmed you would be one of only
two former
federal district court judges serving on
the court the other being justice soto
mayor
i believe your perspective
as a former trial judge will serve you
well on the court you've been
responsible for implementing the
precedent set by higher courts and
because of that you understand the need
for clarity in legal opinions
for achieving consensus wherever
consensus is possible and that has been
your record
it's important to have justices with a
broad set of views and experiences on
the supreme court
and i believe your background and your
experience will only serve to strengthen
the supreme court
i trust that my colleagues on this
committee will recognize that you are
unquestionably qualified for this
position i wish you well i look forward
to learning more about you over the
course of the coming days thank you mr
chairman thanks senator feinstein
senator cornyn of texas
thank you mr chairman uh judge jackson
let me join my colleagues and extending
a warm welcome to you and your family
congratulations
on your nomination
i enjoyed sitting down with you recently
and talking about your experience as
both a lawyer and a judge and how that's
molded your views of our judicial system
in the coming days i hope we can have a
candid conversation
about your record and your judicial
philosophy
as i told you other the other day these
proceedings will be thorough
but civil
as a member of this committee i've had
the opportunity to provide advice and
consent on seven previous supreme court
nominations
this is number
eight i've seen the good
the bad
and the ugly when it comes to the way
the senate conducts these proceedings
and so has the american people
one of the best things i think comes
from this
process is i think this is a teachable
moment
that will remind all of us about the
wisdom of the founders
who wrote a constitution
that made sure that our rights would be
fixed and certain
so that these rights whether they are
the right to keep and bear arms or
the right to practice one's faith
would be preserved from generation to
generation as you know the founders
established three separate branches of
our government
a system of checks and balances if you
will
this was done for the purpose of
preserving individual freedom and
avoiding tyranny
and ensure that our government was
ultimately accountable to the people
from whom all political power derives
article three as you know vests the
supreme court and inferior courts with
the judicial power
but the framers were very clear
the courts are not vested with a
policy-making authority
according to our constitution courts
hear cases and controversies and decide
them
nothing more
nothing less
that's an important distinction to
remember in the days that lie ahead
indeed the framers envisioned that the
courts would be would have a modest but
very important role in our three
branches of government
you'll recall federalist 78 where
alexander hamilton said the courts would
have no influence over either the sword
or the purse
and that it may truly be said
to have neither force nor will
but merely judgment
part of that judgment requires a judge
to go where the law commands whether or
not you personally approve or not
and it starts with deciding cases as
presented and not cherry picking the
facts or the law and starting with the
decision and then justifying it by the
way
by
cherry pick facts and
provisions of the law
while this profamer is provided that the
president would nominate
judges
the framers also set up a framework that
allowed judges once you are confirmed to
exercise independent judgment free from
elections
and politics and so these supreme court
confirmation hearings are really the
only chance we have
as representatives of the people to vet
somebody who will serve the remainder of
their life
unfortunately there are some driven by
their ideology that want the supreme
court to do more than what i've just
described
these are some of the same people who
tried to bully justice breyer into an
early retirement
these activists demand that the court
make policy and deliver results
they can't achieve through the
deliberation compromise and rough and
tumble of legislative politics
and when the court does not deliver the
results they want they attack its
institutional integrity and legitimacy
recent years these radical views have
made their way into the mainstream
on the campaign trail president biden
refused to disavow court packing
two years ago the democratic leader of
the senate went to the supreme court
steps
and threatened two sitting supreme court
justices by name if they did not rule in
a particular way
dark money groups like demand justice
have paid millions of dollars to promote
court packing and so public distrust in
the legitimacy of the supreme court
justice breyer as you know
recently warned of the crippling effect
this politicalization of the court and
its decision-making can have
he said without the public's trust the
court would no longer be able to act as
a check on the other branches of
government
and a guarantee guarantor of the rule of
law threatening the foundations of our
constitutional system
judge i know you know that the courts
are not designed to deliver particular
policy outcomes or to invent new rights
out of whole cloth
that's why it's imperative that we
explore your judicial philosophy during
this hearing
i will say i was a bit troubled when you
that you have not so far provided us
with much clarity on that matter
someone as accomplished as you are
who spent years engaging and thinking
about our constitution and laws has
surely formed a judicial philosophy
this is not your first rodeo
you've had an impressive career judge
as a supreme court clerk a pellet
advocate and trial court judge
i like the fact that you've had such
broad experience in our judicial and
legal system
but there are still unanswered questions
that remain
i'm a bit troubled by some of the
positions you've taken and arguments
that you've made
representing people who
have committed terrorist acts against
the united states
and other dangerous criminals
as someone who has deep respect for the
adversarial system of justice i
understand
the importance of zealous advocacy
but it appears that sometimes this
zealous advocacy has gone beyond the
pale
and in some instances it appears that
your advocacy has bled over
into your decision-making process as a
judge
you've had some cases reversed like all
judges do
but some of them were particularly high
profile when you ruled against a
republican administration
i'm eager to understand why in some
instances you found that you could not
decide a particular issue while in other
instances you enjoined a republican
administration from implementing its
policies
i'm also interested as others have
mentioned
in your opinion why pro-abortion dark
money groups like demand justice and
anti-religious liberty groups are
pouring millions of dollars into a
public campaign in support of your
nomination
judge jackson these are some of the
questions and concerns i have
i assure you that you will have every
opportunity to address these concerns as
the committee evaluates your ability to
fairly and impartially deliver justice
should you be confirmed
so i welcome your
testimony at these hearings and i look
forward to our
give and take thank you very much thanks
senator cornyn senator whitehouse rhode
island
thank you very much chairman welcome
judge jackson i could not be
more delighted to uh have you here
this is a refreshing moment
we are holding a hearing for an
accomplished
experienced
highly qualified
nominee to the supreme court
who came to us not through a dark
money-funded turnstile
but through a fair
and honest selection process
judge jackson has unparalleled breadth
of experience both on and off the bench
she has already been confirmed by the
senate
three times
she serves on what is often called the
second highest court in the land
the dc circuit handles some of the most
difficult and consequential cases in the
nation
often taking up questions that later
come before
the supreme court
judge jackson that will enable you to
jump right in once confirmed
before the dc circuit judge jackson was
a trial judge in the district court in
the district of columbia
ruling on hundreds of cases and
presiding over trials including many
jury trials
judge jackson you have presided
over virtually every kind of case
a federal trial judge can hear across
criminal and civil law
you have more experience
actually trying cases in your courtroom
than any other member of the court
as a member of the u.s sentencing
commission you helped establish the
policies and practices for federal
courts
when deciding criminal punishments
with commissioners from both parties
you helped implement our bipartisan fair
sentencing act
complicated
and consequential work
and we thank you
it matters to me mr chairman that judge
jackson was also a civil litigator and
public defender
she wasn't groomed
in partisan petri dishes
she learned practical
courtroom experience in both civil and
criminal law
how the judicial system works
and how it serves or doesn't serve
different litigants
and i must say that in rhode island we
love
that before you clerked for justice
stephen breyer
you clerked for rhode islander bruce
celia
on the first circuit
judge celia was nominated by ronald
reagan
he is well regarded
by bench
and barr
and he thinks the world
of judge jackson
she is absolutely everything you would
want in a supreme court justice
he told the boston globe in february she
has all the tickets
in terms of her intelligence
her education
her work experience
and her demonstrated judicial
temperament
he actually said that waiting for the
supreme court selection process to take
place
made him feel like a father waiting to
hear his daughter's
college admissions results
we very much appreciate that
rhode island touch to this nomination
judge jackson is steadfastly committed
to the constitution and the rule of law
and her record reflects
the type of even-handedness and
independence
that will make her such a good
supreme court justice
her guiding principle she has said is to
consistently apply
the same level of analytical rigor to a
case
no matter who
or what is involved in the legal action
she says this means you can
quoting again be consistent
in the way you are analyzing the issues
and you can set aside any thoughts about
who is making the arguments
and what advantages any side might take
away from your
opinions if you have fidelity to the
rule of law that is grounded in looking
at only those inputs
she said then
i think you can rule
without fear or favor
mr chairman judge jackson will be an
exemplary justice both because of the
qualities
that she possesses
and because
she did not undergo
a secret pre-selection process to get
here
she is before us on the basis of her own
merit
not on the recommendation of a secretive
right-wing donor operation
hiding behind anonymous multi-million
dollar donations
and aimed at capturing the united states
supreme court as if it were some 19th
century railroad commission
the unpleasant fact is that the present
court is the court that dark money built
anonymous donations funded the
federalist society while it housed the
selection turnstile run by the dark
money donors
anonymous money funded the dark money
group
down the same hallway as the federalist
society
that ran the dark money political
campaigns for the selected justices
and because of all that secrecy
americans are denied any real
understanding of the overlap of all that
dark money
with the political dark money funding
the republican party
which could well explain the wreckage of
senate norms rules and procedures
that accompanied the confirmation
process
of recent nominees
judge jackson's nomination and the
process by which she was
selected stand in sharp contrast
president biden undertook a thorough and
independent review of her record
and she will proceed through a thorough
and fair process here in the senate
we will abide by the new precedents set
by republicans in recent years
but we will not be fabricating new ones
we've already seen dark money groups
use dark money
to run ads
charging that dark money swayed this
selection
we are hearing that again today
ironic
when hundreds of millions of dollars in
right-wing dark money
built
the current
court majority
and still signals its wishes through
flotillas
of dark money front groups posing as
amiki curiae
i welcome the debate on these points
and i look forward to hearing more from
the excellent nominee before us
judge celia
counted the late justice ruth bader
ginsburg an old friend
i see some of the same qualities in
katanji that i saw in ruth he said
humility
the ability to inspire others in a quiet
way
not at the top of her voice
some people he said
have the capacity to inspire by example
and the force of their reason
judge jackson i'm certain
your capacity to inspire through force
of reason will be on display here this
week thank you chairman durbin for your
leadership of the hearing
and thank you judge jackson for being
with us today
thanks senator whitehouse senator lee of
utah
thank you mr chairman and thank you
judge jackson for joining us today i
appreciated the conversation you and i
had in my office a few days ago
and your willingness to uh engage in a
lively interesting conversation during
that look forward to more of that this
week i've enjoyed also meeting your
husband and your two uh lovely daughters
uh they're wonderful people i'm grateful
to you for your service um
your service to the federal judiciary
and as a member of the bar
um you bring to the court as i mentioned
to you last week
um a unique set of uh
of of experiences if you're confirmed
you will
be someone who has served at all three
levels of a federal judiciary and
as a result of that you'll have a
perspective that's different than that
of most who have served on that court
during the modern era
and uh i appreciate your willingness to
be considered and to be here to talk
to us about our questions
i echo what uh many of my colleagues
have said today and that i
am dedicated as i always have been
to making sure that these
hearings are respectful uh
engaging in the politics of personal
destruction is not something we should
ever aspire to it is something that has
occurred
on this committee in the context of
supreme court nominations i'm pleased to
say that it has never been under
republican leadership that such attacks
have occurred and i intend to make sure
that this hearing
is no exception to that there are a few
reasons for that
first and foremost the most obvious is
that
respect to human beings requires it
secondly it's important because
if we focus on personal attacks that
means we will
be betraying our duty under the
constitution and to our constituents to
make sure that we do our jobs fairly
and properly
when we're focused on things that we
have no business doing like bringing
forward
spurious last minute uncorroborated
accusations of her personal nature
we neglect the importance of talking
about
the jurisprudential role the the
philosophy that guides individual
jurists
and they
document that we're all sworn to uphold
and protect the constitution of the
united states
it's also important for an additional
reason a third reason
it has to do with the fact that
having been nominated to this position
we know that you stand a a very decent
likelihood of ultimately being confirmed
to this position
in which case you'll survive everybody
i'm back um i do have mango which i will
be having i did bring my mangos back
down we're going to continue coverage
tribunal
we as a
as a committee as the senate judiciary
committee
not engage in speech or behavior that
would undermine the
legitimacy of the supreme court of the
united states you see it's the
legitimacy of the courts that gives them
their potency
their significance in our system of
government
we all have a duty to make sure that we
don't undermine that very thing that we
purport to be protecting
let me tell you some of the things that
i look for
uh when reviewing a nominee and a few
things that i intend
to focus on in these hearings with you
one of them uh will involve uh any
nominees commitment to judicial
self-restraint to understanding the
judicial role for what it is and what it
is not
uh
any judicial nominee these days
uh will acknowledge that he or she
understands that the role of the judge
is to interpret the law based on what it
says
rather than on the basis of the judge's
personal opinion
this is all very true
it raises questions as to how exactly
that goes about and what steps
what tools
what rhetorical
linguistic devices the the jurist in
question might follow in order to do
that i'm looking for someone who
is ideally
going to echo something that uh justice
amy coney barrett said in her
confirmation proceedings
in which she
likened the constitution
this document uh written by wise men
nearly two and a half centuries ago
uh wise i think it's unfair that tulsi
is not having her say
to the extent we followed that document
it's helped foster the development of
the greatest civilization
the world has ever known
but she she likened this uh and our
commitment to it as a little
like what odysseus
told his crew she said the constitution
is like how odysseus ties himself to the
mast to resist the song of the sirens
she then goes on to to explain that uh
he told the crew do not untie me no
matter how much i beg or plead don't
untie me from the mast
he wanted to avoid the tempting call of
the sirens
attempting to call the sirens is
inherent it's uh
in government itself it's it's
understandable
and that's why we tie ourselves to it
critical to that
is the federal judiciary
the ultimate backstop the the backstop
that's there to resolve disputes
now
the constitution isn't just something
for the courts it's not something that's
owned
exclusively and independently by the
federal judiciary or the supreme court
itself but it does play an important
role because the court's there to
resolve disputes
that arise within the court's
jurisdiction
as to the meaning of a particular
provision of federal law whether in the
constitution itself or as enacted into
law by congress
so we need
a jurist who's willing to to respect
that role and demonstrate judicial
humanity really has a way with words
doesn't he uh an ability to acknowledge
that
there are
a lot of things not within the province
of the courts that entail policy
that the job of the court
of
the judiciary is never to exert will or
force
it is only judgment it's discerning what
the law says
a nominee also i believe needs to show
a steadfast commitment to the principle
of separation of powers
there are a
couple of forms of separation of powers
required by the constitution
uh
along two axes one operates along the
vertical axis we call federalism it says
most of the power
of government within the united states
most powers
that government might exercise or to be
exercised at the state local level
power that's federal is the exception
not the norm in our constitutional
system of government
the other form of separation of powers
operates along the horizontal axis
it's one that recognizes within the
federal government which is limited
we're gonna have one branch our branch
congress that makes the laws
another branch headed by the president
the executive branch that enforces the
and the third branch which interprets
them resolving disputes between
parties coming before the court's
jurisdiction
third
i think one of mike lee's greatest legal
accomplishments in his storied career
was
defending a company storing nuclear
waste
uh wanting to store extra nuclear waste
from italy in the united states that's
his big
sort of legal highlight if a statute or
if a provision of the constitution at
the time of its ratification
this is part of how we tie ourselves to
the mast
making sure that we
undertake efforts to make sure that
we're interpreting it
based on how the public understood those
words regardless of the subject it was
really a profile in courage yeah it was
illegal it was a massive legal profile
in courage saying they should be allowed
to store the nuclear waste in utah this
is how we maintain the rule of law this
is part of how we've we've uh given
force to this uh greatest civilization
that human history has ever recorded
it's through the rule of law and tying
ourselves
to that mass
there are increasing threats
to this
we've seen those threats arise with
efforts to delegitimize the court and i
i'm
sickened every time i see or hear or
experience one of those efforts to
delegitimize it
we've heard some today in in fact
uh comments that i think by their very
nature delegitimize the court another
thing that can delegitimize the court
are arguments made in favor of packing
the supreme court
this was attempted by president franklin
d roosevelt in 1937 it did lasting
damage to the court it didn't succeed as
a legislative matter
but it's arguable that it left a mark
and not a pretty one
there is nothing in the constitution
that requires us to have nine and only
nine justices that is uh under the
constitution left to congress's
determination
but nine is a number that works
it's
worked now for uh 152 years it's not one
that we ought to revisit and it's one
that
supreme court justices of various
ideologies
including your former boss
justice breyer
who might
really enjoy getting to know uh when
serving as the law clerk on the supreme
court enjoyed our conversations with him
uh he justice ginsburg justice thomas
and so many others have been against
that we must protect the court we may
not
protect the court we lose ability to
protect the court if we allow arguments
to take root that are focused on
expanding that and turning the court
into a political body thank you mr
chairman thanks senator lee senator
klobuchar of minnesota thank you very
much
chairman durbin and thank you ranking
member grassley judge jackson welcome
we met recently in my office and we have
seen you in this committee before and we
are so happy to have you back
if senator whitehouse is pleased that
you once clerked for a rhode island
judge we in minnesota are equally happy
that you are wearing bold purple today
winning over both prince and minnesota
vikings fans the world over
i'd like to welcome your husband patrick
and your two daughters and your other
family members and friends
it is clear that your family starting
with your parents who i got to meet who
are sitting there
in the front row
who once worked as teachers that your
family has been a constant source of
inspiration and support for you
my mom taught second grade until she was
70 years old so i know first hand it's
pretty great to have a parent who was
also a teacher and they never stopped
checking your spelling
as a lawyer who also balanced work with
parenthood myself i particularly enjoyed
your story judge about sitting with your
dad you had a coloring book and he was
studying his law books
while these hearings are truly an
opportunity as my colleagues have
pointed out for americans to get to know
your legal acumen we also learn about
your background your experiences your
values and for so many of us including
people watching this hearing across the
country our values start with our family
there's something else particularly
special about this hearing of course
you've been nominated by president biden
as the first black woman to serve on the
supreme court
that's historic with
115 justices having served so far in our
history you're the first black woman and
it's long past time
in fact this entire hearing is about
opening things up the hearing room we've
opened it up with actual guests
for the first time in a while
and you're opening up the senate and the
court by virtue of your very presence
you judge are opening a door that's long
been shut to so many and by virtue of
your strong presence your skills your
experience you are showing so many
little girls and little boys across the
country that anything and everything is
possible
we're here to carry out one of this
committee's most solemn constitutional
obligations to advise and consent on
president biden's nomination to the
supreme court but this is also a time
for us to consider the supreme court's
place in our democracy and how it
impacts people
you've been nominated to justice briar's
seat
you clerked for him and i know he's been
and is a wonderful mentor to you
so i'd like to start with some of his
words justice breyer once wrote that the
supreme court
must help maintain public acceptance of
its own legitimacy
he said
it can do this best by helping ensure
that the constitution remains workable
in a broad sense of the term
specifically it can and should interpret
the constitution in a way that works for
the people of today
making it work for the people of today
those words his words are highly
relevant to the court
and justice breyer didn't just write
about those values in his 27 years on
the court he lived them he approached
cases with a pragmatic view of the law
and he understood that reference to the
constitution requires not just a respect
for the past although it does that
but also an eye toward the future
as we are here to confirm a new justice
for his seat i urge my colleagues to
remember his words about how the court
must consider the effect of its actions
on people's lives how it must be able to
see the real people at the other end of
its rulings like americans who are one
supreme court decision away from losing
their health insurance or one court
decision away from the ability to make
their own health care choices or the
dreamers who the folks who are
commenting that amy klobuchar always
sounds like she's on the verge of tears
i genuinely don't know if she has like a
vocal dysphonia type of condition i
don't know
or whether it's emotion based or whether
it's just her voice i don't know it all
have been suggested just to exercise
their constitutional right to vote
the court decides cases with
life-changing consequences for people it
makes decisions that dictate health and
safety standards for workers protections
for seniors whether we can have clean
air and clean water the supreme court
issues rulings that can determine
who can make their voices heard in our
democracy and how they can do it
so judge jackson this week i look
forward to hearing more on your views
about the real world implications of the
law
and about how you will respect the
constitution and legal precedent
all the while striving to ensure we have
a court that works for the american
people
judge i believe you have exactly the
sort of understanding of what the law
means in people's lives that americans
would want in a justice you're from a
family that knows something about making
it work
both of your parents attended segregated
primary schools and later became
teachers and when your dad set his
sights on becoming a lawyer your mom
figured out how to support the family
while he attended law school
after being a star debater in high
school you went on to graduate magna [ __ ]
laude in college and went on to graduate
with honors from law school after law
school you clerked for federal judges
nominated by both democratic and
republican presidents and of course you
had the honor of serving as a clerk to
justice breyer these aren't just lines
on your resume they show that you have
worked to apply the law at every level
of the federal system and beyond those
credentials you have the perspectives of
someone who has seen the law through the
eyes of those closest to it your brother
worked as a police officer in baltimore
one of your uncles was a detective and
another was the chief of police of the
city of miami you know what it means for
a person to put their life on the line
to defend the rule of law it is no
surprise to me that you receive the
letter that senator durbin mentioned the
letter of support from the fraternal
order of police and as a former federal
public defender you also understand that
for a justice system to be truly
workable it must account for those who
lack the resources to defend themselves
and you would be the first justice to
bring that experience to the court
judge i believe it is because of your
experience and respect for the law that
the senate has confirmed you three times
with bipartisan support
as vice chair and commissioner of the
u.s sentencing commission judge on the
d.c district court and most recently the
d.c circuit court of appeals in each of
these roles you've lived up to that
bipartisan support as a commissioner
over 90 percent of the votes you
participated in were either unanimous or
voice votes as a district court judge
you wrote nearly 600 opinions applying
the law and precedent to the facts
fairly and impartially without regard to
your personal views i will note that if
you are confirmed you will join justice
sotomayor as the only other justice on
the bench with experience as a trial
court judge as a circuit court judge you
have written decisions joined by judges
appointed by presidents of both parties
and let's not forget you have nine years
of judicial experience more than four
other justices currently on the court
prior to their confirmations not that
we're counting
judge jackson and i expect this to come
through loudoun yeah but do we know her
lsat score
experience and record of a jurist who is
dedicated to the fair application of the
law committed to consensus and
determined to make sure that the court
and the constitution work for the people
of today
and one last point
judge
your confirmation hearing comes at a
moment in our history when the people of
this country are once again seeing this
time in ukraine
that democracy can never be taken for
granted
eternal vigilance it's been said
is the price of liberty
last week i was at the ukrainian polish
border with refugees streaming through
checkpoints leaving everything they had
behind with only a suitcase and a
backpack walking into the loving arms of
their neighbors in poland a country with
a long hard history of having been
invaded by nazis and russians and
prussians and habsburgs
as our ambassador there told me at this
moment in history the people of poland
are achieving the dreams their
grandparents could never realize they
are saying to their ukrainian neighbors
we value freedom and respect your
democracy we value you so much that we
will take you into our homes and into
our hearts we will open our doors and
not shut you bit off topic
and this horrendous war against evil and
the courage of the ukrainian people is
happening at the very same time our
country is opening our minds
after being separated through a two-year
pandemic from our neighbors not only
around the world
but in our own country in our own towns
this moment bestowed upon us a new
opportunity to see one another again and
to be part of our own democracy to
respect each other's rights and views to
see that we are not a nation of 300 plus
million silos
instead we are a nation that must
re-embrace the simple principle that
unites us as americans and that is that
our country is so much bigger in what
unites us than what divides us
that's the pivotal moment we are in
that's your moment it's a time for us to
consider what the courts mean to our
democracy to recall how the
framers envisioned the courts to work as
a ballast in our system of government
and to rededicate ourselves to the
sacred protection of our rights and the
upholding of our constitution so as we
move forward with these hearings let us
be grounded in the central role of the
court and the constitution in our
democracy of what it means to our system
of government that we can never take for
granted and how we must always be
vigilant that it is serving the people
judge jackson i'm confident you will
come to the bench as a justice with a
bedrock appreciation of what the
constitution and the law means to
america with the real world perspective
we need thank you for your willingness
to serve at this important time wow
thanks senator klobuchar senator cruz of
texas oh god
thank you mr chairman oh no judge
jackson congratulations on your
nomination
11 107 men and women have served as
members of the house of representatives
1
994 men and women has served as members
of the united states senate
only 115 men and women have served as
supreme court justices and he's really
jealous the position to which you have
been nominated
is extraordinarily important
and that is why the senate is given the
responsibility for advice and consent
under the constitution
because the job matters
immensely
supreme court confirmations were not
always controversial in fact bushrod
washington when nominated to the supreme
court in 1798 was confirmed the very
next day
so what changed
well what changed is starting in the
1960s and the 1970s the supreme court's
role in our society changed dramatically
what was going on then the supreme court
became a policy-making body rather than
a merely judicial body oh my god just a
moment ago my colleague senator
klobuchar said we should consider the
supreme court's place in our democracy
well starting in the 60s and 70s the
supreme court decided its place in our
democracy at least too many justices was
to set aside the democratic decisions of
the people
it sounds like they gave minorities
rights during the civil rights movement
cruz is not pleased
our democratic colleagues want the
supreme court
to be anti-democratic
our democratic colleagues get frustrated
with the democratic process
when they can't pass gun control laws
because the american people don't
support them they want unelected judges
to mandate those same laws instead
law after law after law that they can't
get through the democratic process the
democrats have decided it's much simpler
to convince five lawyers in black robes
than to try to convince 330 million
americans
that is why supreme court confirmation
hearings have become so contentious is
because the supreme court has arrogated
to itself a responsibility the
constitution doesn't give it
which is to make contested policy
decisions and take them away from the
american people
now what should this hearing be and what
should it not be well you've heard a
number of members on the republican side
of the aisle quite clear on what it
should not be this will not be a
political circus
this will not be the kind of character
smear
that sadly our democratic colleagues
have gotten very good at um it might be
and it's important to note you know a
couple of years ago i was doing
my weekly podcast and i was on with a
noted liberal intellectual
who made a comment something to the
effect of well both sides do this both
sides
smear supreme court justices
and i was forced to laugh out loud and
say look i understand that's a pretty
good talking point
it just happens not to be true
it is only one side of the aisle the
democratic isle
that went so into the gutter
with judge robert bork
that they invented a new verb to bork
someone
it is only one side of the aisle that
with justice clarence thomas
was so reprehensible
that is the president who nominated him
president george herbert walker bush
wrote at the time quote what's happening
to clarence thomas is just plain
horrible all the groups that tried to
beat him up on abortion or affirmative
action have now come out of the woodwork
they are trying to destroy a decent man
this is an ugly process and one can see
clearly
why so many good people elect to stay
out of public life
as justice thomas observed in that
hearing
what happened there was to use his words
a high-tech lynching
and i would note the chairman who
presided over that disgrace
was joe biden
whoa
and then most of the members of this
committee remember the confirmation
hearing of brett kavanaugh
one of the lowest moments in the history
of this committee
kavanaugh's nomination was one of the
lowest moments in the history of the
court
didn't refer them to the fbi didn't ask
for investigations hid them and then
leaked them
against the wishes
of the
complainant and we began
a circus that featured spartacus moments
featured such nuts
as michael avenatti
cnn breathlessly for some months
described as a possible democratic
presidential candidate that's before
presumably he became a felon in recent
months the avenatti thing was really
dumb
judge jackson i can assure you
that your hearing will feature none of
that
disgraceful behavior it'll feature other
disgraceful no one is going to inquire
into your teenage dating habits
no one is going to ask you with mock
severity do you like beer
that's not to say this hearing
oh man should be
non-substantive dear god and
non-vigorous
in this hearing this committee has a
responsibility to focus on issues to
focus on your record to focus on
substance
to do our very best to ascertain what
kind of justice you would be
and a couple of
straw men
it is no longer the case that supreme
court confirmation hearings are merely
about qualifications
there are some who say well if the
justices qualified the senate should
confirm there was a time that was the
case
our democratic colleagues have abandoned
that standard long ago
our democratic colleagues then senator
joe biden was perfectly happy to vote
against john roberts someone who was
unquestionably qualified for the court
he was perfectly happy to vote against
sam alito someone who was unquestionably
qualified for the court and indeed
every member of our democratic
colleagues who was here at the time
participated in the first ever
filibuster of a supreme court justice on
partisan lines
with justice neil gorsuch
they did so for someone unquestionably
qualified
but they had a political agenda and so
every one of them happily
filibustered justice gorsuch gorsuch
likewise it's not about race
we will see democrats in the media
suggest that any senator that
is skeptical of your nomination that
questions you vigorously or that dares
to vote against you must somehow harbor
racial enemas
if that were the standard
i would note we are sitting on a
committee where multiple members of this
committee the senior democrats in the
committee happily filibustered judge
janice rogers brown a very qualified
african-american woman nominated the d.c
circuit
and they did so precisely because they
wanted to prevent
judge brown
from becoming justice brown the first
african-american women joe biden was
among the democrats filibustering
the first african-american woman
nominated pretty vile
the senior democrats on this committee
also
filibustered miguel estrada
as the staff for senator ted kennedy
said in writing at the time
the democrats filibustered miguel
estrada quote
because he is hispanic
they were explicitly racial
if you dare
if you are hispanic or african-american
and you dare depart
from their political orthodoxy they will
crush you they will attack you they will
slander you they will filibuster you
so this is not about race this is no
this is about ted cruz trying to get
some excerpts from this on hannity
tonight
chairman dermot quoted paul simon and he
said
history will judge quote did she
restrict freedom
or did she expand it
i agree with that
the reason the american people care
about the supreme court is it is
integral to protecting or taking away
our constitutional
rights when it comes to free speech
this committee should inquire will you
protect the rights of americans to speak
to say unpopular ideas to say ideas that
the government doesn't want you to say
that you nonetheless have a right to say
will you protect freedom or restrict it
when it comes to religious liberty
will a justice vote to protect your
right to live according to your faith
and according to your conscience
or will a justice vote to crush
religious liberty and strip those rights
away
the second amendment
will a justice vote to defend your
second amendment rights to keep and bear
arms to defend your family to defend
your children
or will a justice rule for everybody
asking when he's going to ask a question
the answer is tomorrow or wednesday
today is opening statements opening
statements today not questions
will a justice protect the rights of the
people the rights of state legislatures
to enact laws protecting innocent life
protecting unborn life
stopping abominations like partial birth
abortion
or will a justice view her job
as a super legislator
striking down all such rights
school choice
will a justice protect the rights of
kids to get a quality education or will
a justice legislate from the bench and
shut down school choice programs across
this country and crime
we are seeing murder rates carjacking
rates crime rates skyrocketing across
the country
in significant part because political
sorrows back district attorneys because
of democratic efforts to abolish the
police
and part of the democratic effort to
abolish the police is nominating
justices that consistently side with
violent criminals release violent
criminals refuse to enforce the law and
that results in jeopardizing innocent
citizens oh boy so all of those
questions are fair game
will you follow the law what does your
record indicate will you protect the
rights of every american citizen
regardless of race regardless of party
regardless of views
that's what the focus of this hearing
should be
okay thank you senator senator coons
from delaware
and thank you chairman durbin of ranking
member grassley
judge jackson
congratulations on your nomination it is
a joy and a blessing to welcome you and
your family and your supporters here
this morning
as both senators klobuchar and cruz have
laid out in great and forceful detail
the decisions of the united states
supreme court have daily impact regular
bearing on the lived experience of
americans and that is in part why
hearings for this important role are so
contentious
i have been looking forward to this day
since president biden announced your
nomination in february and over the next
several days members of this committee
will have the privilege of helping
introduce you to the american people so
that they can
gain the sense of confidence that i have
in your values your skills your
competence
and the necessity of confirming you to
the supreme court
we'll be inviting you to speak directly
to the american public and share the
lived experiences
the strong qualifications the judicial
temperament and the strength of
character that made you not only an
historic nominee to the supreme court
but an outstanding one as well
i want to acknowledge up front that
president biden selected you to fill the
seat on the court being vacated by
justice breyer a justice whom i admire
and in the work he's done as a jurist
over decades has shown us a model of a
supreme court justice in his 42 years on
the federal bench 30 years on the
supreme court he's lived up to the
highest ideals of american jurisprudence
he has served with wisdom with fairness
and respect for the constitution
the laws of our nation and its people he
has a keen legal mind and a love of the
law that are obvious to anyone who's
heard him ask questions or read his
decisions and certainly to someone who
clerked for him on the supreme court and
who has had the benefit of his
mentorship over many many years
you've had broad experience in your
stellar legal career that'll make you a
unique contributor to the supreme court
you've worked as a lawyer or as a judge
in just about every level of our legal
system engaging in just about every area
of federal law
your experiences as a private practice
attorney with large law firms as a
federal public defender as vice chair of
the u.s sentencing commission and your
near decade of service as a federal
judge have given you insights into the
ways that our constitution our statutes
our sentencing guidelines and judicial
decisions all come together
to directly impact individuals families
and our communities
you're able to perceive the full sweep
of our law
without losing sight of the human beings
the individuals and families impacted by
it caught up in it
and it is critically important in my
view that we have justices on the
supreme court with this practical and
proximate view
you began your legal career with the
invaluable experience of clerking for
judges at the federal district court at
the circuit court and for justice breyer
on the supreme court judges appointed
good question i believe that they have
up to 20 minutes on statements although
i don't think any any of them have taken
the full amount defender service
as part of this work you took on complex
cases
involving challenging and unsettled
areas of the law you worked pro bono on
behalf of clients without regard to
their political views or the political
consequences of those cases
and you helped ensure bedrock
constitutional guarantees in our legal
system held strong
even in times of great stress and crisis
the work you did in these roles
distinguished you as a talented
appellate litigator maybe it's 10
minutes legal mind
you helped to craft policy as counsel to
the u.s sentencing commission the
independent agency within the judicial
branch that establishes sentencing
guidelines followed by all federal
judges and then years later you served
again on the commission as its vice
chair
while on the u.s sentencing commission
you partnered with colleagues whose
perspectives on the law spanned the
ideological spectrum and together you
enacted meaningful reforms designed to
reduce unjust disparities and increase
fairness in sentencing
the days ahead i expect to discuss your
sentencing commission experience with
you in some detail
nearly all the decisions you were part
of while serving on the commission were
unanimous
and they grew out of a careful
consideration of highly complex numerous
factors and involved commissioners
working hard to achieve common ground
in at least one notable instance you
ended up joining two conservative
commissioners to oppose an amendment
because you thought the law required a
different result and you followed the
law
something that often gets lost in our
debates and discussions about the
supreme court is that many in some terms
a majority of supreme court decisions
are unanimous
or decided by very broad majorities
these decisions are every bit as
critical to the rule of law and the
functioning and legitimacy of the court
as the handful that are very contentious
and widely discussed publicly your
service on the sentencing commission and
your time on the circuit court have
prepared you to be a positive force for
consensus among the justices in this
challenging chapter in american history
i also think we will have some extended
discussions this week about your record
of service on the federal bench
you were confirmed to the federal
district court for the district of
columbia in 2013 and have written more
than 500 published opinions you were
confirmed to the dc circuit court of
appeals last year
and in your near decade as a judge
you've authored opinions in cases
spanning a myriad of complicated issues
from administrative law to civil rights
from criminal environmental matters
labor and employment law national
security and sovereign immunity
immigration law and many more
your rich complex and deep decisional
record gives us the best possible
evidence of what kind of justice you
will be
and i've concluded you are judicious
and impartial
great qualities for injustice
in every case you methodically consider
the party's arguments the relevant facts
and the law including of course the
foundation of the constitution the text
of applicable statutes
and the precedents that apply and
ultimately from what i've seen you come
to a decision based on that methodology
not on any particular policy preferences
or activism
this committee has also received a
striking outpouring of support for your
nomination from a very broad range of
sources i'm certain we'll be hearing
about some of the more enthusiastic
statements in detail in the coming days
but in several of the letters i've had a
chance to review personally i've been
struck these were letters from lawyers
that held appointed positions in
republican administration
administrations letters from a prominent
law enforcement organizations federal
judges appointed by republican
presidents they praise your
qualifications your character your
experience and your commitment to
even-handed and impartial judging and
the rule of law
this is the fourth supreme court
nomination process in which i'm
participating as a senator and i know
our role in confirming a justice to the
highest court is among the most solemn
obligations we have as senators
as we begin this week's hearings i
remain hopeful
that we can come together as a committee
and engage in respectful good faith
bipartisan consideration of your
nomination
i look forward to your testimony this
week i'm excited so many of my
colleagues have had a chance to get to
know you a bit to meet with you to talk
with you one-on-one and get a sense of
your
your character experiences and your
background and then we'll have the
opportunity to question you to bring
that out in more detail
i have every expectation that at the end
of this week's hearings it'll be clear
to all that you are impeccably qualified
in the law
and i think it'll be plain to any
american watching you have a
demonstrated record of excellence as a
jurist you will decide cases as a
justice on the basis of the facts and
the law
and that you will be faithful to the
constitution
it's also my hope folks will get a
chance to meet the family that shaped
you
it was
delightful to have a few moments to get
to talk with your parents and your
brother before we began today
and to reflect on how having parents
graduates of hbcu's public school
teachers who then went on to great
careers of accomplishment
johnny brown esquire
and dr ellery brown set a great standard
but frankly to me one of the most
memorable sentences before this was in
talking to your brother kitaj who said
oh i'm not surprised to be here at all
this was the sort of thing for which my
sister was destined from the very start
destined perhaps
but today you are beginning a process of
walking through this door because of
courage
humility determination and a commitment
to excellence
just as another person in american
history ruby bridges
walked through
a critical door in our history with her
chin held high her back held straight
and a fierce determination to make a
difference so you too today begin the
process of walking through this next
open door
with the sort of
sparkling wit
brilliant mind and commitment to
excellence that will make its mark in
american history i look forward to your
opening and to this week thank you your
honor
thank you senator coons senator sas of
nebraska
thank you chairman and uh chris was
tough to follow that was uh a good
flourish at the end um judge
congratulations on your nomination uh
thanks for spending time in my office
with me uh congratulations to your
daughters and your family more broadly
this is a big day for for lots of folks
in your in your family
today the senate takes up our
constitutional duty to advise the
president on his nominee to the supreme
court the senate's advice and consent
clause and our role
is especially important these days when
we all republicans and democrats agree
that the nine justices of the court
exercise a lot of power
over policy decisions surely much much
more power than our constitution's
framers ever anticipated so let's talk
about how we got into this mess
we're here in part because of decades
and decades of recklessness by all three
branches not just one but by all three
congress the article one branch
fails to carry out our tasks responsibly
and regularly rather than make tough
policy choices we pass incredibly vague
laws and then just push the details on
down pennsylvania avenue to unelected
bureaucrats in the article 2 branch then
the head of the executive branch
meanwhile
whichever party he or she comes from
grabs more and more power with their
pens and their phones
and finally the supreme court at the top
of article 3 tends to overstep the
bounds that the constitution sets on
judicial power the court has ignored
restrictions on its authority inserting
itself into policy debates they're
supposed to be entrusted exclusively to
the two political branches and what do
we mean by that what do we mean when we
say articles one and two are political
it means that the people are in power
over articles one and two but not in the
long term over article three the men and
women in article one and article two are
supposed to be answering directly to the
american people and importantly the
american people get to hire us or get to
fire us every two four or six years
but rather than honor the roles given to
each branch activist judges usurp the
powers given to articles one and two
which articles one and two were
complicit in this overreach
many years of corroding our
constitutional order have contributed to
the polarization and the viciousness
that are poisoning our politics more
broadly we all know that our civic
health and our civic life is not healthy
and as was mentioned at the beginning of
the hearing it's at least good that this
one got kicked off without a bunch of
yokels having to be arrested and carried
from the room when chairman grassley
tried to speak a couple years ago one of
these it took like an hour to get
started that kind of nonsense the
theatrics that happen at these hearings
are because of a broader problem
as textualists and originalists have
sought to return the court to its
historic role the supreme court
nomination process has been increasingly
punctuated with not just those theatrics
but also with lots of personal attacks
that's not what this process is supposed
to be this process is supposed to be a
careful thorough investigation of a
nominee's record to help the senate make
an informed decision on a nominee's
fitness for a lifetime appointment
that's why these hearings are supposed
to be different not because people act
like jack wagons but because the people
before us nominated by the president are
potentially going to serve for a
lifetime that office a supreme court
justice is incredibly important yet it's
also carefully circumscribed precisely
because it's a lifetime responsibility
but we know that it's been a long time
since this process has worked like that
instead this is often a staging ground
for nasty evidence-free personal attacks
we started down this road of character
assassination in the 1980s with judge
bork's hearings and senators have been
engaged in disgusting theatrics ever
since the most recent supreme court
nominee was subjected to repeated
accusations that were nothing more than
unfiltered religious bigotry against her
the nominee before her was accused of
serial rape
aided by members of this committee
if this process were conducted in good
faith miguel and estrada and janice
rogers brown might well be on the
supreme court today but their opponents
lied and bullied rather than accepted
principled minority judges we've gotten
so used to this kind of bullying that
two years ago
the current senate majority leader stood
on the steps of the united states
capital and screamed threats against two
sitting justices of the supreme court
that they would quote reap the whirlwind
if they ruled in a way that didn't align
with chuck schumer's political
preferences that's weird
we should all be able to pause and say
that's weird that kind of behavior
shouldn't happen
this process is broken but it's a
product of a broader brokenness in the
erosion of our constitutional structure
a lot of people are willing to take a
sledgehammer to the structure if it
offers them a quick political win and
it's no coincidence that as more of us
embrace and ends justifies the means
philosophy of our jobs
which are supposed to be jobs of public
trust our politics becomes uglier more
brutal and more pathological
well we have an opportunity today to do
something different and we can
demonstrate that the congress can carry
out its constitutional duty responsibly
without a lot of that past ugliness
judge jackson has served for the last
nine months on the prestigious u.s
circuit court of appeals for the d.c
circuit and before that you spent eight
years on the d.c district court she has
a long record of public service and a
long roster of colleagues and friends
who will testify to her professionalism
the president believes that she should
have a lifetime seat on the supreme
court and it's the job of this body to
evaluate that recommendation on its
merits so what should we be looking for
we should start with judicial philosophy
the senate should have a good sense of
the principles that will guide a
nominee's decision-making on the bench
a robust and thorough judicial
philosophy can help help us understand
how when faced with difficult or
unprecedented decisions as the court
occasionally is and i would just like to
compliment senator coons a minute ago
mentioning that a huge huge share of
decisions that come out of the supreme
court are actually nine to zero they
just tend to not be the ones that make
the headlines but they're incredibly
important um and the public trust that
we need to restore in all three branches
of government would be well served by us
paying more attention to some of those
nine zero decisions but the ones that
tend to be most contentious
and the ones that tend to generate the
most headlines are the occasions where
judges have to figure out what they do
in areas which are gray and ambiguous
where the law might not be clear and so
it makes it's incredibly important for a
judge to tell us how she or he works out
those principles in times that are new
and confusing this will make their
rulings more durable and sound and it
will help rebuild public trust in the
court and in the government more
generally unfortunately too many of the
court's decisions do not rest on solid
constitutional foundations and reliable
legal reasoning justices have too often
written decisions to claim partisan
policy victories and then retrofit bad
legal reasoning or political
decision-making to justify that ruling
some of the most divisive cases in the
court's recent history fit that bill
it's for that reason that while we
should all respect the ginsburg rule the
idea that judges sitting before this
panel should not weigh in on
hypothetical cases that are likely to
come before the court nominees do
nonetheless have a duty to be very clear
about their judicial philosophy their
legal views and their interpretive
principles the american people should
not be asked to consent to any nominee
who operates on principles that are
obscure confused or concealed that means
that each of us has a job to do in these
hearings it is our job on the senate
judiciary committee to ask questions
that help give the american people a
clear view of the nominee
it's judge jackson's job to make her
philosophy clear and well understood and
at the end of a constructive hearing a
nominee will have given us a good sense
of how she thinks about the
constitutional structure what it does
and doesn't do and the key pillars that
support it most fundamentally the
separation of powers and our carefully
calibrated system of checks and balances
throughout this process we should all
remember that a supreme court justice is
not a lawmaker by another name a supreme
court justice performs a crucial but
limited function in our political system
namely to interpret and fairly apply the
text to the law as written and as
understood at the time it was adopted
a forthcoming nominee will make clear a
commitment to uphold that purpose which
is the court's true purpose not the
purpose concocted for it by decades of
political use abuse and overreach a good
nominee will show a commitment to the
strict protection of enumerated rights
not the fabrication of unenumerated
rights through contorted readings an
excellent nominee will offer a robust
judicial philosophy that makes sound
decisions more likely and more trusted
by the public
chairman i look forward to hearing from
judge jackson this coming week
thanks senator sass senator blumenthal
of connecticut thanks mr chairman uh
good afternoon
judge
thank you for being here thank you to
your family and thank you to
president biden
for his vision and wisdom and courage
in nominating you
first on a personal note for all of your
extraordinary
accomplishments and your immense
distinction you have shown two qualities
that are rare among powerful
accomplished people kindness and humor
and you're obviously a good listener
because you're doing a lot of listening
here today
uh
as you've seen
we're likely to
hear more than a few straw men today
worn talking points imagined grievances
but this hearing really should be about
you
not about
us
historic is a word often overused in
this place where a lot of history
is made but today seems truly to merit
it
certainly it is an inflection point
an inflection pinnacle
for our nation the appointment of a
black woman to the united states supreme
court let's be very blunt
should have happened years ago
this day is a
giant leap into the present for our
country and for the court
the appointment of a black woman
to the court
means that
your
service will make the court look more
like america
hopefully too it will make the court
think
more like
america
we will never know in detail all of the
challenges and obstacles that you've
overcome
to be here
today
but we know for sure that you will bring
an important perspective in fact a
unique perspective
to a court
that deeply needs it
representation matters for the
legitimacy and credibility
of our judicial system judges are the
face and voice
of justice people walking into
your courtroom or any other in this
country look to the human being
not just to the robes
too often our courts are isolated
seemingly sterile marble halls lacking
emotional intelligence
or a sensitivity to the impact they have
on people a fact that you
clearly and dramatically
understand
what really knocked me over in our
meeting was the fact that
you discussed your job as a judge
in terms of the people who are affected
by
your rulings the people whose lives are
touched
by the justice system whether it's
victims as criminal defendants
or as people dealing with a personal or
professional
conflict you will be the first public
defender on the court
you understand our justice system
uniquely through the eyes of people who
couldn't afford
a lawyer
they couldn't afford
their own lawyer
and you
advocated for them
you will also bring the court
extraordinary intellect
and character as well as diverse
personal and indeed
professional experience your presence
will ensure the court more fully and
deeply understands the lives and
experiences
of everyday
americans you grew up as a daughter of
two public servants
public school teachers and
administrators
you're the niece of uncles who have
impressive law enforcement
careers including one as miami's chief
of police
and you also have family members who
have struggled as do
every american
and you've advocated for defendants
standing accused of serious crimes as
well as sentencing
defendants who have been convicted
of such crimes you are an immensely
devoted parent
who has achieved eye-popping
professional distinction
you've had a long career already as a
distinguished jurist
in fact you would bring more experience
as a trial judge than any current
justice on the supreme court
now i'd like to address directly
the importance of your work as a public
defender i was a prosecutor and a law
enforcement for a while four years as
u.s attorney in
20 years as connecticut's attorney
general
and as a prosecutor i know
the system works best when there are
good lawyers on both sides my worst
nightmare as a prosecutor was a
defendant representing himself
my second worst nightmare
was
an incompetent counsel representing a
defendant
because i know effective representation
on the other side means
more likely an error-free
trial
i'd also like to
address
an issue that's been raised
first by senator durbin and then by
senator graham i'm likely to be followed
by
one or more colleagues who have raised
allegations
about your record that are simply
unfounded in fact and
indeed irresponsible they're unproven
and unprovable
they're simply false
one of the first lessons
that you learn as a prosecutor
is
never to promise a jury evidence
that you don't have
there is simply no evidence to support
these unfounded attacks in fact a
commentary in the national
review
cited by senator durbin said
about those
allegations they are meritless
to the point of demagoguery
importantly your record as a jurist also
reveals impartiality
you're proven unifier
and a consensus builder someone who can
build bridges among colleagues even
adversaries
not surprisingly you've been confirmed
on a bipartisan basis three times by the
senate
you've received glowing endorsements
from former judges who are stalwarts of
the conservative movement
the court needs a bridge builder
now more than ever it has become more
polarized more politicized more divided
than at any point in our
history and it faces a crisis of
legitimacy
as a result
dark money special interest groups have
sought to radically reshape the court
their recent selection of justices was
to a remarkable degree
outsourced to ideological groups with
the express aim of remaking the court
in the image of the far-right
conservative movement
this court has signaled
that it will continue to overthrow
well-established precedents
after disingenuously promising us
members of this committee
that it would respect those
precedents instead it
threatens to adopt preferred policy
views
i revere
the united states supreme court i clerk
for a justice myself harry blackman i've
argued four times before the court i'm
deeply concerned
that
this court
is careening toward a precipice that
will gravely threaten
its role in our history that it is out
of step with america
and that it is losing the trust and
respect of the american people that are
essential
to its authority
trust in the united states supreme court
is at a new law
a new low
the supreme court has no armies no
police force to enforce its decisions
its authority depends on its credibility
and the respect and trust of the
american people
my hope is that you will help
to restore that trust that you will
re-inspire
the confidence of the american people
in the court
i traveled as did my colleague senator
klobuchar to poland
just a week ago
and i saw people
fleeing bombs and destruction
people
mostly women and children who wanted
nothing more than the kinds of freedoms
that we have in this country
we have an obligation to preserve them
and my hope is that your nomination will
help us do so thank you i look forward
to your
testimony
thank you senator blumenthal senator
grassley just asked me what the plan is
the plan is to recognize two more
senators and then take a 30-minute break
for lunch is that okay sid
judge all right we have
senator hawley of missouri
thank you very much mr chairman judge
congratulations on your nomination it's
nice to see you again congratulations to
all of your family i know this is a big
moment for you and for them and rightly
so i enjoyed our meeting a couple of
weeks ago you know as i've said to folks
who've asked about it one of the things
i particularly appreciated about our
meeting besides how much time you gave
me was how candid and forthcoming you
were which i really respected and i look
forward to a candid conversation again
in the days that come and by the way i'm
admiring how you're sitting so uh
stoically through all of this all this
senator talk but i'm looking forward to
visiting with you again you did me the
the honor when we sat down of being very
candid and i hope i was candid with you
i've been candid since i want to be
candid with you today so you know
exactly what it is i want to talk about
and uh so you know exactly where my head
is at so let me let me say
a few things that i'm concerned about
aspects of your record that trouble me
this will come as no surprise i've said
it in public already but i want to be
again very candid in the interest of an
open and honest discussion and specific
so here are i hope in the next couple of
days some of the cases
from your time on the on the court the
district court the federal district
court that i hope that we can talk about
let me just run through a few of them so
you know exactly which ones i mean
united states versus hawkins this was a
child pornography case where the
defendant distributed multiple images of
child porn possessed dozens more
including videos
the federal sentencing guidelines
recommended a sentence of 97 to 121
months in prison
prosecutors recommended 24 months in
prison
judge jackson gave the defendant three
months in prison
united states versus chasen there's
that case the defendant possessed 48
files of child pornography
the federal guidelines recommended 78 to
97 months in prison the prosecutor
recommended the same
judge jackson sentenced him to 28 months
united states versus cooper
there the defendant possessed dozens of
images of child pornography
and uh distributed i should say
distributed dozens of images of child
pornography possessed over 600.
the federal guidelines recommended 151
to 188 months in prison that's a long
time the prosecutor recommended 72
months
judge jackson gave the defendant 60
months
which was the lowest sentence permitted
by the law
the united states versus down that's a
case where the defendant distributed
33 graphic images and videos of child
sexual assault to an anonymous messaging
app unfortunately practice that's
becoming more common the federal
guidelines recommended 70 to 87 months
in prison
the prosecutor recommended 70 months in
prison church jackson sentenced him to
only 60 months again that's the lowest
level that was permitted by law in that
case
the united states versus stewart
the defendant there distributed scores
of images of children suffering sexual
abuse
the guidelines recommended 97 to 121
months in prison the prosecutor
recommended 97 months in prison
judge jackson gave him 57 months
in the united states versus sears
the defendant distributed over 100
videos of child pornography
the guidelines recommended 97 to 121
months in prison
the prosecutor recommended 97 months in
prison
judge jackson gave him 71 months in the
united states versus savage the
defendant was convicted of traveling
across state lines to engage in sexual
intercourse with a child and also
possess six
separate thumb drives of child
pornography
the guidelines recommended 46 to 57
months in prison the prosecutor
recommended 49 months in prison judge
jackson sentenced him to 37
months in prison now those are seven
cases
that represent as near as we can tell
all of judge jackson's cases dealing
with child pornography from her time on
the district court in which she had some
discretion to hand down a sentence
there's some other cases in which the
law she didn't have any discretion the
law bound the sentence that she had to
had to give and what concerns me and
i've been very candid about this is that
in every case in each of these seven
judge jackson handed down a lenient
sentence that was below what the federal
guidelines recommended and below what
prosecutors requested and so i think
there's a lot to talk about there and i
look forward to talking about it now i
will note
that some have said that the federal
sentencing guidelines are too harsh
on child sex crimes especially child
pornography i've heard that
argument a lot in recent days the
chairman quoted
someone earlier today who takes that
point of view i'll just be honest i
can't say that i agree with that
i mean the amount of child pornography
in circulation has absolutely exploded
in recent years here's a new york times
report from 2019 i'm quoting now
last year tech companies reported over
45 million online photos and videos
of children being sexually abused more
than double
what they found the previous year
the report goes on to say this
20 years ago these online images were a
problem
10 years ago they were an epidemic
now the crisis is at a breaking point
unfortunately it's even worse than that
just last week the national center for
missing and exploited children
reported finding 85
million files of child pornography in in
2021 of course this committee has heard
testimony from prosecutors and others
who are grappling with the problem of of
how to get at this point and those who
distribute it how to prosecute them and
hold them accountable here's my point i
think it's difficult against this
backdrop to argue
that the sentencing guidelines are too
harsh or outmoded or that we should be
somehow treating child porn offenders
more leniently than the guidelines
recommend but i want to be clear about
this but those arguments that i've just
been rehearsing those who say that
those are that's not what judge jackson
has said
she hasn't had the chance yet to respond
to this and she deserves that chance so
others have made these arguments i don't
agree with them but i think it's
important we hear from judge jackson and
we'll have the chance to in coming days
and i i think again the the candor that
judge jackson has shown previously i
look forward to and she deserves the
ability to speak for herself on this
issue
so i will just say in closing mr
chairman some have asked why did i raise
these questions ahead of the hearing why
not wait until the hearing
and
spring them on judge jackson as it were
and my answer to that is very simple i'm
not interested in trapping judge jackson
i'm not interested in trying to play
gotcha i'm interested in her answers
because i found in our time together
that she was enormously thoughtful
enormously accomplished
and i suspect has a coherent view and
explanation and a set of thinking way of
thinking about this that i look forward
to hearing and i think she deserves the
chance to talk about it i think the
american people deserve the chance to
hear her answers
so they're my concerns judge they're the
cases i imagine there'll be others that
we can talk about on other subjects but
i'd like to talk about those so you know
exactly where i'm coming from thanks
again for giving me the time a few weeks
ago congratulations again i look forward
to finally hearing from you tomorrow
thank you mr chairman thank you senator
hawley uh certainly the judge deserves
to be heard on that type of a charge
senator carono
thank you mr chairman
judge jackson aloha to you and your
family and all of your friends i also
note that there are members of the u.s
house here to support you as well as
members of the public so aloha too all
of you congratulations
judge jackson on all that you have
accomplished throughout your life and
career
i realize that a lot of your background
and experiences have already been cited
but there are things that are worth
repeating so i'm going to repeat some of
them
you're the national champion in speech
and debate as a high schooler
you have undergraduate and law degrees
from harvard each with honors three
clerkships in federal court including
one at the supreme court for justice
breyer whom you have been nominated to
replace
you have an accomplished career as a
lawyer
at the trial and appellate levels both
in private practice and as a public
defender
two stints at the u.s sentencing
commission including as vice chair
nine years as a federal judge first in
the d.c district court and currently in
the d.c circuit court
and now you've been nominated to the
united states supreme court
i have enjoyed reviewing your record and
getting to know you over the past few
weeks and now the american people will
get to know you over the course of this
week
beyond your impressive credentials here
are a few other things i want the
american people to know
you're born in washington dc to two
public school teachers
you moved to miami florida at a young
age so your dad could go to law school
and you were inspired to pursue a career
in law by watching your dad study for
his law classes at the kitchen table
you first considered attending harvard a
thought that hadn't previously entered
your mind after attending a speech and
debate competition on the harvard campus
during high school
and then you thought this is possible
you've been confirmed three times by the
senate all on a bipartisan basis first
to the sentencing commission and later
to be a judge on the d.c district court
and the d.c circuit court
you're the second generation in your
family to get to go to college and work
extremely hard to get to where you are
today
you are a wife and mother of two
children
clearly your life and your career have
more than prepared you to serve on our
nation's highest court
which is why it is no surprise that
there is broad consensus across the
political spectrum that you are an
imminently qualified and fair
person to serve on the secretary on the
supreme court
as former 4th circuit judge michael
luddick a george h.w bush appointee said
you are quote
as highly credentialed and experienced
in the law as any nominee in history
end quote
in history that's over 200 years
23 attorneys general said judge jackson
is a highly qualified legal mind who has
been at the forefront of the legal field
for decades and will serve our nation
well as the first black woman to serve
on the u.s supreme court
a group of law enforcement officers from
across the country said quote judge
jackson bridges a depth of character
brings a depth of character public
service and judicial service that leads
to but one conclusion she is imminently
qualified to serve on the supreme court
of the united states end quote
you are an accomplished jurors having
issued nearly 600 opinions
that demonstrate a clear
even-handed approach to the law you have
sided with workers
with employers
for and against the government four
prosecutors and four criminal defendants
former d.c circuit judge thomas griffith
a george w
bush appointee summed it up best when he
said you judge jackson quote
will adjudicate based on the facts and
the law and not
as a partisan end quote
having reviewed your record i strongly
agree with the statement
but you are not just extremely qualified
to serve as a supreme court your
nomination is of course an historic one
the supreme court has existed for over
233 years
and over 115 justices in the history of
the supreme court
only five of them have been women only
two have been black and not a single one
has been a black woman
this is a court that has decided cases
that have had sweeping
effects on everyday life
as my a number of my colleagues have
pointed out including
decisions that have solidified rights
for the lgbtq plus
community
decisions that have impart women
that have strengthened unions and more
but this is also the same court that has
throughout the course of history upheld
slavery
jim crow laws and the unlawful
internment of japanese americans
for over 233 years the individual making
decisions that have altered the course
of this country
have almost exclusively been white men
it's pretty remarkable when you consider
the power that this court has and the
historical lack of diversity of the
people who exercise that power the
justices
but instead of celebrating the long
overdue diversity just
judge jackson would bring to the court
some of my republican colleagues and
public figures have attempted to
undermine your qualifications through
their pejorative use of the term
affordable
affirmative action
and they have implied you were solely
nominated due to your race and not for
other factors
apparently some have even claimed that
you need to
show your lsat scores
to determine whether you are a top legal
mind
this is incredibly offensive and
condescending
let me be clear your nomination is about
not about fulfilling a quota
it is about time
it's about time that we have a highly
qualified highly accomplished black
woman on the supreme court it's about
time our highest court better reflects
the country it serves
it's about time that black women and
girls across the country can finally see
themselves who look like them sitting
on the highest court making decisions
that will impact
their lives
and they will know that it is possible
for them to do the same
one cannot overstate the importance of
representation
your experiences and your background as
a trial judge a public defender a mother
a black woman and so much more provide
you with a uniquely different
perspective than any of the eight other
justices on the court
like your mentor justice breyer i know
you will encoura you will engage
with the other justices both liberal and
conservative
you are a consensus builder to share
their perspectives
challenge their views and shape the
court's
direction
for the better
with the personal and professional
diversity your brain you will expand the
experience and knowledge
of the supreme court and the decisions
the court makes will be better as a
result
before i end i also wanted to mention i
was so glad to hear you reference
constance
baker motley during your introductory
press conference at the white house
constance baker motley
was an icon of the civil rights movement
as a lawyer for the naacp legal defense
fund she helped craft the argument in
brown v board of education
that finally
put an end to separate but equal
she was the first black woman to argue
before the supreme court
ultimately arguing ten cases before the
court and winning nine including the
case that allowed james meredith to
enroll
at the university of mississippi
she became the first black woman
appointed as a federal judge
serving on the southern district of new
york for 20 years and in a world free
from discrimination she may have been
the first black woman to sit on the
supreme court some 50 years ago
as you said at your press conference you
stand on judge motley's shoulders
i have no doubt there will be a
generation of young girls who will stand
on yours
i also have no doubt that you will
respond forcefully
to some of the allegations that have
been lodged against you judge jackson
i congratulate you
and your family on this historic
nomination
i look forward to hearing from you this
week mahalo and aloha
thank you senator hirono now we're going
to break and return at 205 when you will
hear this and we're back in business in
the meantime uh thank my colleagues and
i particularly thank the judge for her
patience
and with that uh the chairman of the
senate judiciary committee dick durbin
of illinois has gaveled
this
opening session of the hearings for
judge katanji brown jackson nominated to
serve on the supreme court he's gavel
that to a recess they'll be back as you
heard in 35 minutes after taking a lunch
break 22 members of the senate judiciary
committee we've heard 15 of them
make their opening statements
i think it's fair to say judge jackson
has sat patiently through it all looking
at each senator as he he or she
addressed her at one point we heard
senator josh hawley of missouri describe
her as stoic
he said you've been here stoically
listening
to to each one of us
but it is also brought into uh it's as
if the specter hanging over this
this committee room has been previous
confirmation hearings because we've
heard from the democrats
words praising judge jackson and then
many of the of the republicans while uh
giving her credit for her credentials uh
saying they look forward to hearing from
her are also saying reminding everybody
that previous nominations to the supr to
the
excuse me to the supreme court
have not been met with the kind of uh
respect that they believe that she'll
receive joining me as we uh look at what
we heard for the last two and a half
hours our correspondent lisa desjardins
she's been in the hearing room john yang
who's also been listening very closely
at jeff bennett who's at the white house
and
marcia coyle of the national law journal
with me in the studio and lisa i'm going
to go to you first because you've been
in the hearing room
this this specter hanging over the
hearing room of previous
confirmations was a theme from almost
every one of the republican senators
it's as if
uh that the divisions in that body
couldn't be starker
that was incredibly striking to me judy
this hearing reminded me more of
hearings from a time almost out of
memory now with
for example confirmation hearings of for
example now chief justice john roberts
when we heard sort of more academic more
philosophical discussions looking at
almost exclusively
a nominee's record but you could tell
that this is a country and a capital
that have been through some very
tumultuous and turbulent years including
the last two supreme court nominations
especially that of now justice kavanaugh
you can tell
every member of that committee is still
scarred by that experience democrats
upset that he is on the supreme court
republicans upset for how they see him
as being attacked and you can also see
something important from these opening
statements judy everyone wants this one
to be different they don't want it to
have that kind of personal animosity
either toward the nominee or between
senators which we have seen on a regular
basis for the last four or five years
no question uh jeff bennett to you at
the white house where they clearly gave
a lot of thought to this nomination they
went through a fairly methodical process
and right selecting uh judge jackson uh
how much do you think they expected
that there would be this kind of a
welcome for her
you know it's interesting judy in many
ways one of the reasons why judge
jackson had been
at the top of president biden's
shortlist all along was because she was
a known quantity she has been through
this process before she's been sent
confirmed uh three times and that's in
addition to her qualifications her
judicial philosophy the fact that she uh
clerked for justice prior that was
important to president biden i'm told
that that they had that sort of close
connection but the hearings so far have
progressed in exactly the way i'm told
the white house expected and the way
that they had planned for it to include
the allegations from senator hawley uh
the notion from some republicans that uh
judge jackson is soft on crime the white
house views that as being sort of a
proxy argument not really having
anything to do with judge jackson so
much as it has to do with the republican
argument in this election year against
democrats more broadly and so the white
house has prepared for that in the sense
that after the break after we hear from
the senators
one of the people introducing
the judge will be a conservative judge
who was appointed by a former president
george w bush the white house also touts
the fact that the fraternal order of
police has endorsed judge jackson that
she has the endorsement of police chiefs
and of some 80-plus
attorneys general so the idea that she
would be soft on crime does not in any
way align with the endorsements of now
hundreds of elected or appointed
officials both democrat and republican
judy absolutely and what we're what
we're watching uh john yang to bring you
into this is of course uh if you will
what's what will emerge two different
sides of the qualifications the
experience that judge jackson brings to
this nomination what did you hear in
this morning statements that gives you a
sense of what it what what is going to
be the focus of the rest of today of the
next two days
well i think as jeff said you heard the
republicans focusing on her time as a
public defender with which she did work
for some of the guantanamo uh defendants
uh josh hawley talking about her
sentencing decisions in child
pornography cases when she was a trial
judge and from the democrats i think
various also is predictably you heard
them focus on her personal story uh the
the
the child of parents who had gone to
gone to segregated
public schools who rose to become
administrators in public schools or
father an attorney for the miami school
board
her mother a principal in the miami
public schools uh talked about also to
to to counter the arguments about her uh
work as a public defender and the
allegations that she soft on crime talk
about an uncle who was the miami police
chief another uncle who was a uh
a detective i believe in in florida and
a brother who was on the baltimore city
police uh drug squad doing undercover
work uh so i think that you've sort of
heard those the battle lines drawn uh
you'll hear more of it in the the
opening hearings i would expect that uh
judge jackson in her uh
opening statement will continue to talk
about her personal story uh and then
hear more of that as the questioning
continues or begins uh tuesday and and
wednesday
john yang is watching these hearings
along with us marcia coyle here with me
uh in uh in the studio marcia she's only
served on the circuit court for a short
time she just uh was confirmed by this
very committee
just last year but she does have years
of experience for the committee to look
over pour over
in in some instances to find
evidence and and to raise questions that
they want to pursue as they make this
decision oh absolutely i mean she wrote
on the district court over 500 opinions
and that's a treasure trove in just
about every area that
this district court would deal with so
there's there are lots of areas of the
law that they can look at and also her
work uh when she was uh on the
sentencing commission the u.s sentencing
commission
which
crafts guidelines for judges in how to
sentence certain crimes uh there they
have received certain documents
concerning that
uh and and also you know when she was a
federal public defender she handled
cases mostly appellate cases so they can
look at briefs that she wrote
when she was there as well as when she
was in private practice with one
particular law firm she focused on
supreme court and appellate briefs so
there's lots and lots of material there
judy and i think um we're going to see a
broader range of questions than at least
these opening statements
seem to give us right now and there were
a couple of hints
her judicial philosophy is going to be
explored meaning how does she approach
cases and we're going to see again that
old debate over whether you're an
originalist or you're a living
constitutionalist
uh so we'll see that and then there are
more current issues that they want to
explore like what what are her her
feelings about the expansion of the u.s
supreme court and other reforms that
have been brought up and i think we will
also hear very traditional questions you
know looking at her views of the various
amendments to the constitution so much
that could come up and probably will
come up yes uh as this day goes on as
and as we get into tomorrow and the next
day lisa desjardins i want to come back
to you because um the role of the court
um i think we heard
senator blumenthal speak about how the
court is at a low point in terms of
public trust right now that is that's
also become front and center uh in these
in these confirmation hearings hasn't it
it has and you heard that from again a
number of senators senator mike lee of
utah saying
point blank we must protect the court
which is an unusual thing to hear about
the supreme court usually it is the
other branches that have concerns about
their legitimacy or their popularity
even with american voters but here there
is a sense across the parties that the
supreme court itself is becoming seen as
more and more political and that's a
danger overall to democracy
what's interesting here judy is whether
this vote on judge jackson will itself
become political
as i know jeff has reported
the white house is hoping for some
republican votes on this committee there
are two republicans senator lindsey
graham senator john cornyn who voted for
judge jackson just last year when she
was moving to the appellate court in
committee now i spoke to senator cornyn
this morning about that he said the
supreme court is a higher bar he seems
to be signaling that he's
not on board a yes vote at this point in
fact kind of i'm reading between the
lines here he seems to be leaning away
from it senator graham as you heard
fascinating remarks today he clearly is
still upset about the fact that south
carolina judge j michelle childs was not
chosen despite very heavy lobbying by
himself and also by democrats in south
carolina including jim clyburn
he was openly upset about that openly
thought that she had been attacked uh by
the left unfairly and we're going to
hear a lot about that um you know
judge jackson didn't have anything to do
with that ad spending um
but she is going to hear questions about
any sort of liberal leadings and it's
really going to be an excuse for these
senators to bring up another subject the
idea of dark money something both
parties are concerned about as we heard
today and we heard several senators
bring up dark money in fact lisa i'm
glad you brought that up because we do
have a clip from the morning hearing
this is uh senator lindsey graham in
south carolina uh
repeating uh in in his view
what happened to the
nomination of someone he was backing
he wanted a democratic president to
nominate judge michelle childs of south
carolina but here's part of what senator
graham had to say
so you're the beneficiary of a lot
you're the beneficiary of republican
nominees having their life turned upside
down
and it didn't work
so i'm hoping that we can have a hearing
this respectful that's informative
that's challenging
and
president biden has every right to pick
who he'd like to pick that comes with
winning the white house
and i've been very inclined to support
the picks
of people that i would not have chosen
but this is a new game for the supreme
court
and this game is particularly disturbing
to me
because there's been a wholesale effort
of the left
to take down a nominee for my state
and i don't like it very much
and if that's the way the game's going
to be played then
i'll have a response
and i don't expect it to be
reward that way of playing the game
and jeff bennett who's joining us from
the white house what is the biden white
house saying about this
charge from senator graham and others
that there was this concerted effort a
lot of money put into making sure that
michelle chiles was not chosen well
they're rejecting it out of hand judy
and i can tell you uh one white house
official texted me during the hearings
today and said something to the effect
of given all of the airing of grievances
from republicans you would never know
that conservatives have a six to three
supermajority on the supreme court i can
tell you based on my reporting that one
of the reasons judge jackson emerged as
president biden's pick is because
democrats on the judiciary committee to
include the chairman dick durbin made
clear to the white house that if they
wanted to move forward with this process
in an expeditious manner the white house
had to send them someone they knew
a typical supreme court confirmation
process takes anywhere between two to
three months the process for justice amy
coney barrett was basically a lightning
quick 30 days this process from top to
bottom will be somewhere in the 42 to 45
day range in order for that to happen
democrats i'm told were adamant that it
had to be someone who had been
previously vetted uh who was known to
the committee and who was known to
members of the senate more generally and
of the three on the short list to
include judge childs judge krueger and
judge jackson judge jackson was the only
one who fit that bill
add to that qualifications temperament
philosophy all of that that was one of
the reasons why she emerged and frankly
from the beginning had always been
the front-runner so this notion that
dark money and these these sort of you
know shady leftist groups put their
thumb on the scale and that was the
thing that uh made president biden
select judge jackson just doesn't hold
up based on all of the reporting that
i've done
thank you jeff and and and back to john
yang right now i mean this this issue
john of money and the role of money
in uh in determining who's chosen and
and how this process goes this is a
familiar one this is not the first time
this has come up that's right and
actually it's uh senator whitehouse uh
of uh rhode island on the committee
who's made this uh a bit of a uh uh
a hobby horse may be too pejorative a
term but it's something that he has
talked a lot about he's given a number
of speeches
in committee he spent a lot of time he
spent
a lot of his questioning during
justice amy
coney barrett's confirmation hearings
talking about it but i also thought it
was interesting that one of the
republican senators i forgive me i've
forgotten which one talked about how
these this these left-wing groups come
up with a list of judges for president
biden
to nominate as candidates for nominees
to the supreme court forgetting of
course that the republicans uh the
conservative think tanks essentially
drew up a list and one of the ways that
donald trump in his 2016 campaign
appealed to conservatives was to have a
list of supreme court justices uh that
was drawn up by uh uh some conservative
groups uh that uh that he would consider
if he was elected yeah and that and that
uh it's the it's the uh federalist
society i think that's been mentioned
the most uh
there have been others but i know that's
that's one that that comes immediately
to mine marcia coyle i want to raise
with you i mean as as we talk about
these it's almost as if the
the winds are blowing at hurricane
strength outside the hearing room and
and
wafting through the the doors how incre
how increasingly have
these supreme court nominees handled
this i mean they are the subject of of
enormous political forces uh in many
ways completely out of their control as
they sit there before this committee how
have they handled this process i think
it depends on the nominee uh as i look
back over time
i can see john roberts sitting at that
table i actually covered that and he was
cool
calm very professional
he leaned forward to engage each senator
answered their questions within the
bounds of what he could say someone like
elena kagan
dealt with it with humor you know and
she does that on the bench as well uh
justice sotomayor you know very
straightforward the trial judge you know
saying i only apply you know i look at
the facts in the law and i apply the law
to the facts uh so uh a lot it's going
to be interesting to see how judge
jackson responds to each senator
and this is why i look at these hearings
i try to step back and say this is
really a conversation
between her and america and we will be
judging you know her temperament and how
she deals with it i was thinking marcia
i was watching judge jackson as uh
senator hawley was bringing up the the
uh list of uh sentencing
rulings she handed down for uh
individuals accused in child pornography
cases and he was sharing in some graphic
detail what people were accused of
having done she was stu she was making
notes she was looking down making notes
on each one of his points uh i think
demonstrating she's listening she's
taking it seriously
um
where does that lead i mean this is a
this is part of her record um and part
of the defense has been that that it was
there was a general sentiment that the
recommended
uh length of sentences was had been too
long and that there was a reason for
them to be shorter but where do you see
that criticism headed well i i suppose
it can play with certain people who are
very worried about crime uh and you know
the statistics on crime but the truth of
the matter is
if you if you look at what she did on
the sentencing commission it was
bipartisan republicans and democrats
agreed on the recommendations what she
did as a judge was within the mainstream
of what judges were doing they all knew
that the guidelines in this area on
child pornography were a mess
and so judges were
i think i saw 70 percent of federal
trial judges were giving sentences that
were below the recommended guidelines
because they knew there was a problem
seventy percent seventy percent now um
cnn and the washington post have fact
checked uh senator hawley's claims and
they've found them inaccurate and often
out of context well you may think well
the media's biased but
i know
a sentencing scholar uh douglas berman
out at ohio state university school of
law who it's this is his life work and
he's looked at this as well and he
provides that context that these
sentences were a mess and she was doing
what other federal trial judges were
doing trying to make these sentences
more appropriate to the crime that was
committed as we are in the middle of
what the senate judiciary committee is
calling a lunch break uh in the midst of
this first day of confirmation hearings
for judge katanji brown jackson to the
supreme court we are talking with our
correspondents we're hearing from marcia
coyle and we also want to bring in two
other analysts who are very familiar
with the process of supreme court
nomination they are melody barnes she is
the executive director
of the karsh institute of democracy at
the university of virginia she
previously served in the obama
administration as director of the white
house domestic policy council and as
chief counsel to senator ted kennedy on
the judiciary committee
and kurt levy he is the president of the
committee for justice it's a non-profit
that advocates for conservative judicial
appointments and we welcome both of you
to our special coverage of this supreme
court uh nom
nomination hearing uh kurt levy i'm
going to go to you first i think i'm
hearing i can do that is that right i
i'm listening technically okay uh kurt
levy we're discussing uh josh hawley's
emphasis
on what what judge brown judge brown
jackson has handed down in cases
involving individuals charged with child
pornography and we just heard marcia
coyle say some of the experts in that
field say this is actually part of a
trend
of moving those sentences to fewer years
in prison
shed some light if you can on why this
is a
a subject of such great interest to
senator hawley
well it's a subject of great interest to
to a lot of my uh colleagues on the
right um
you know i don't know if it's legitimate
or not i mean i don't know if i would
use the term soft on crime she's liberal
on crime but that's what you would
expect she works as a public defender uh
you know very few people who aren't
liberal on on criminal issues take those
jobs
and she was appointed by a liberal
president
at the urging of groups on the left so
of course she's liberal including
liberal on crime but i don't think that
that you know there are other questions
about her but i don't think that makes
her unqualified in any way
melody barnes a liberal on crime is that
is that a a description that you think
fits
uh well it's great to be with you judy i
don't think that that's an accurate
moniker for her
for several different reasons one if you
look at this issue that senator hawley
has focused on and i think marcia coyle
was alluding to this one there are not
only judges that have sentenced in the
same way that she has and some of them
trump appointees and others
judges that are nominees that senator
hawley supported but you also have
prosecutors that were recommending
sentences that were below the level of
the sentencing guidelines
again she is well within the boundaries
of what the norm is not liberal not
conservative but what the norm is and
people who have been nominated and
confirmed by republicans and democrats i
think it's also important to remember
that she has enormous support from law
enforcement organizations the fraternal
order of the police other and analysts
and journalists from the newshour
newshour have commented on this and
she's got the support of conservative
judges who have watched her in the
courtroom so i don't think liberal on
crime is the way to describe her i think
she's actually consistent
with others and working in an area that
is very complex and doesn't necessarily
fall in the norm of what the public may
hear not understanding how the
sentencing guidelines work currently the
how does your
take if you will on judge jackson square
with the endorsement of
some of these law enforcement
organizations and of
conservative judges we're going to be
hearing from a conservative
judge
just thomas griffith who's going to be
introducing judge jackson later today
how does how do you square all that
well i mean it's very common for
nominees of both parties to get support
from the other side um you know we've
seen it with the three uh trump nominees
and we're seeing it again here i mean
that's politics i don't really draw a
conclusion one way or the other um but
to get back to uh being soft or liberal
on crime it's not just the sentences
again
a lot of my colleagues are concerned by
the fact that she's um
spoken out against sex offender
registries um
again i you know i'm more libertarian i
i think they're legitimate concerns um
the supreme court did uphold um sex
offender registries but i don't think
it's a crazy position to um
to think that there's constitutional
problems with them so again i don't
think anyone takes a job as a public
defender who's not liberal on crime but
that's fine um we expected this to be a
liberal appointee and
we expected the groups on the left to
push for someone who's very liberal and
they did it's not uh out of the ordinary
melody barnes what does i mean the the
fact that she was a public defender has
gotten a lot of attention
um i i
what do you think that
lends to our understanding of who she is
what kind of justice she would be well
first of all i think it believe lends
itself to helping people understand that
she believes in the constitution and i
think senator klobuchar leaned into this
point and it was an important one
unless you believe that
criminal defendants should be in front
of juries and in front of a court
without representation you would want to
have a public defender and i think other
members of the judiciary committee made
the point maybe it was senator leahy
that when he was a prosecutor he was
comforted by and in fact he was made
better by
the fact that you had a strong defense
for a criminal defendant i mean that is
in fact embodied in the constitutional
law so i don't think that
that is a way to
kind of pin her as being liberal or soft
on crime
what i think you have to do is look at
her overall record i mean she has worked
in the private sector she's worked at
the sentencing commission she has been a
judge she has a number of opinions
hundreds of opinions um to review and
her support from conservatives is not
ordinary i worked on the senate
judiciary committee i think having
michael ledeck and others supporting her
rep
leads us to understand her to be someone
who's a fair and judicious jurist kurt
levy i want to come back to you on on
some of the points made by
senators blumenthal
and senator whitehouse it's something
that's come up in the last few minutes
in our conversation and that is this
money
out there and the the
the if you will the fix is in uh in
in uh appointing uh jud appointing
rather uh
individuals to the supreme court by
republican presidents they have to be
vetted in so many words by
uh these
secret groups uh referring i think to
the federalist society and others um
how do you i mean what is the what is
the response to that accusation because
we heard senator whitehouse
speak about it we heard senator
blumenthal go on at length about it
yeah i mean you would think that this
was a gop nominee the way they uh the
way they focused on it
they have almost an obsession with this
conspiracy theory
that um the federalist society and other
groups on the right using dark money
somehow tell the white house you know
what judge to pick
you know i've been involved to one
degree or another with you know the last
10 or so nominations and i don't see any
signs of that the federalist society
doesn't take positions doesn't endorse
um nominees members of the federalist
society who tend to be conservative
certainly expressed their opinion much
like many people on the left express
their opinion about uh
about judge jackson but i can tell you
uh you know
i i know who people at the federal
society might have favored and those are
certainly not always the people who are
chosen the white house uh makes the
decision but they do listen whether
democratic white house or republican
white house they do
listen to outside groups and you know
that's our concern
uh too that of the three people on the
shortlist um we thought that judge
jackson was was probably the
least uh
attractive um
for what we were looking for and yet she
was picked because groups on the left
love her she's a darling of groups on
the left and again that's
that's her right i'm not going to
criticize it you know there are people
on the uh conservative judges who are
darlings of uh you know groups groups on
the right but to pretend that this is
sort of um
you know that when republicans pick
nominees it's political and when
democrats do it it's just done almost
almost by the hand of god with no regard
to uh political considerations first of
all the biggest political consideration
was when they said they were going to
pick a black woman i mean black women
are as roughly as qualified as any other
demographic group you would pick but to
limit it to
you know
three percent of the lawyers out there
that was done for political reasons it
was done to help biden in the in the
primaries and again so just admit it
it's not
unusual to have political considerations
don't don't pretend otherwise and and
speaking of that melody barnes and a
number of individuals have pointed out
that this
um
saying i'm going to choose a black woman
reminded them of president reagan saying
i'm going to choose
a
woman yes i mean that has been well
certainly when nominee or candidate
biden
said this it picked up a lot of
attention and then when there was the
opportunity to make the nomination
and i think you know look
there have been 115
people to sit on the supreme court and
you don't need both hands to count the
number of women and people of color and
there have only been two other african
americans to sit on the supreme court
and i think what president biden was
saying during the campaign and what i
would think we would all want um is to
recognize that having diversity of
opinion of all kinds of opinion and
experience is important and the idea
that since 1789
there have only been two
african-americans and no
african-american women who are qualified
to sit on this court and to bring the
set of experiences not just of race not
just of gender but all of the
experiences that they have to the
deliberations of the highest court in
the land is simply preposterous um so i
think beyond a political statement it
was a statement about increasing the
diversity that sits on the supreme court
and determines the the
reading of the constitution for all of
us
melody barnes kurt levy i'm going to
come back to you all
in a bit uh just to remind everyone
watching we are in a lunch break at the
senate judiciary committee uh
confirmation hearings there you see the
uh the senate hearing room uh
confirmation hearings for
judge katanji brown jackson to the
supreme court marcia coyle here with me
uh in the in the studio marcia there is
a um
sameness to these hearings in a sense uh
that each side is coming at it from
their own perspective and yet you're
dealing with a completely
different individual different set of
set of um uh experiences her her
background uh we heard senator klobuchar
refer to that um and others i mean we
there's a lot to look at here in her
life and you were speaking about it
earlier yes she went to an ivy league
school she went to harvard uh did very
well there um excelled in undergraduate
and law school
um
and she's gone on to have a a remarkable
career for someone who's what 50 years
old that's right judy and and i sort of
put aside what happens uh in in these
opening statements in terms of past
grievances because each side has their
own grievance certainly during the
barrett hearings we heard from the
democrats you know they're still
seething over what happened to merrick
garland or didn't happen to merrick
garland and also
very upset about the rush they claimed
to get justice barrett on the bench so
to me um this had to get out of the way
you know they had to say this and
starting tomorrow
i'm hoping we're going to see more meat
in terms of the questioning and get to
know her better uh through those
questions uh we'll just have to wait and
see um i i think it'll play out uh much
as uh some of the senators have said in
terms of the issues that they're
interested in
jeff bennett i want to come back to you
at the white house uh remind us of the
process
that these nominees go through um it's
not as if they just walk in and say okay
have at it ask me questions yeah
she has met with every single of the 22
senators on the committee i think i
heard them say she's met with 40 or 50
senators overall she plans to meet with
as many as as she can but a lot goes
into this
that's true and one of the reasons why a
nominee in this case judge jackson meets
with more than just the republican
senators who are on the committee is
because if the white house wants the
ultimate result to be bipartisan
especially with the makeup of the senate
judiciary committee in its current form
if she is to pick up a republican vote
it might come from with outside the
committee it might come from senator
susan collins or mitt romney or maybe
even lisa murkowski but this process
started you could actually say this
process started during the transition uh
when biden aids were pulling together
lists of people to occupy seats on the
federal judiciary a list that was
diverse not just in terms of race and
gender but of based on a professional
background and so from there judge
jackson was among the the first judges
named to the bench by president biden
and and from there she'd always been on
his radar and when she was ultimately
confirmed or rather ultimately nominated
uh then began the process of what are
called courtesy calls those uh sort of
informal meet and greets where a nominee
will meet with the senator those
interactions in their offices usually
inform the kind of questions that the
senator then asks the nominee in those
hearings fast forward to this week
tomorrow we will see two days of the
typical sort of question and answer that
most people i think would
come to expect during some of these
hearings thursday there will be a
hearing focused on outside groups you'll
hear from legal experts to talk about uh
how judge jackson could be beneficial
on the court and then from there the
senate
under the direction of democrats and and
chairman durbin and leader schumer hope
to wrap this process up by april 8th
before the senate leaves on its two-week
easter break so that's a fairly
truncated uh confirmation process but
again given the fact that the senate is
split on this razor's edge 50 50 and
democrats realize there are heartbeat
away not to be dramatic about it but
that's the absolute truth from losing
their majority so they're trying to move
as quickly as possible but also be a
deliberate and methodical in their
approach jeff bennett at the white house
we're watching the hearing room closely
as senator dick durbin prepares to gavel
them back
into business we watched judge jackson
there with a former
democratic senator from alabama doug
jones who's been advising her through
this process
uh i'm going to be turning anchor duties
over to amna nawaz uh uh after this but
right now let's go back to the hearing
this is the senator from arkansas
senator cotton for opening statement
i welcome judge jackson
and her family and i congratulate her on
her nomination
this is an important occasion the biden
administration is waging a war on the
rule of law the separation of powers and
the constitution
the lawlessness of the administration
highlights the importance of judges who
faithfully apply the law
to understand the ongoing power grab
let's consider president biden's failed
nominee to lead the departments of
justice
uh
atf the manny nominated can only be
described as an anti-gun zealot
thanks to the courage of some of my
democratic colleagues
that
nominee was withdrawn
but it's disturbing that the president
was ever willing to nominate someone who
planned to shred the second amendment
and ban virtually every modern hunting
rifle in america
just a few weeks ago the bite
administration tried to twist the
authority of the occupational safety and
health administration a relatively
obscure agency designed to regulate
things like ladder safety on
construction sites
and use it as a weapon to force
virtually every american to choose
between getting vaccinated or losing
their livelihood
thankfully the supreme court struck down
that unlawful power grab
or look at the southern border where joe
biden and his secretary of homeland
security steadfastly refused to enforce
our laws
as a result two million illegal aliens
streamed across our borders just last
year
and less than six months ago the
attorney general of the united states
himself a former judge
ordered that federal prosecutors the fbi
and even the national security division
of the department of justice be
mobilized against parents who dared
question the entrenched teachers unions
who are poisoning their children with
racist vitriol known as critical race
theory
as justice galileo is fond of saying
every banana republic has a bill of
rights
but it's nothing more than a parchment
barrier without free and fair elections
without separated powers without the
rule of law and without an independent
judiciary
to uphold it all
perhaps recognizing what justice scalia
meant the progressive left is not just
threatening the rights of americans but
our very system of constitutional
government
those on the left including some of my
colleagues here in the senate including
on this committee
want to pack the supreme court
i would hope that anyone nominated to
the court would have no problem
echoing the words of justice ginsburg
and justice breyer
both of these liberal lions have said
that expanding the supreme court to
achieve favored legal and political
outcomes
is a dangerous idea
and that the court should have nine
justices and no more but for some
political outcomes on the court
are exactly their goal
the democratic leader senator schumer
stood on the steps of the supreme court
almost exactly two years ago and yelled
at specific justices quote
you have unleashed the whirlwind and you
will pay the price and added quote
you won't know what hits you if you go
forward with these awful decisions end
quote
the chief justice rightly condemned
these words
again i hope any nominee to the court
would be comfortable condemning these
words from senator schumer as well
the supreme court is not the only
constitutional limit on power that the
left would like to destroy
the associate attorney general of the
united states has said that she believes
that every single american every single
american
and every single institution in this
country
are inherently racist and the very
concepts of the rule of law and equal
justice for all are actually quote code
words that's what she said code words
for some kind of twisted secret racism
these threats the rule of law are not
merely theoretical
we are witnessing a breakdown
of society
there are many americans who no longer
feel safe today parents are scared
to walk down the streets that used to be
free from crime
in 2020 anarchists rioters and left-wing
street militias
raged across the country
and murders increased at the fastest
rate in
history and in the first year of the
bible administration violent crime got
even worse
it's no coincidence that this violence
violence came as localities and states
pushed to defund the police and reduce
the punishment for
criminals career criminals are
committing violent crimes and going free
under the guise of a supposedly more
equitable justice system
and liberal judges who have more
sympathy for the victimizers than for
the victims are a big part of the
problem
the bite administration is committed to
these soft on crime policies like ending
cash bail to create a catch and release
system for violent criminals
progressive soros prosecutors who are
supported by the biden administration
have nullified entire sections of law to
destroy our criminal justice system from
within
the consequences are obvious
skyrocketing violent crime embolden
gangs and drug overdoses reaching
numbers never before seen
in american history
if judge jackson is confirmed her
decisions will have a direct impact on
the safety of the american people
so we're going to look at her past
decisions and her statements
because the best predictor of future
performance is past performance
that brings us to today
we're asked to determine whether the
president's nominee to the supreme court
is able and willing to meet these vital
challenges
i enjoyed meeting with
judge jackson last week in my office
we had a good conversation and over the
next few days i'll have many more
questions
let's be clear about this the
confirmation hearing is not a test of
how well nominees can filibuster
or how many questions they can avoid
answering
it's true that there is a tradition of
avoiding
any stances on how one might rule in
specific cases if confirmed and there's
good reason for that
but that's not a license to refuse to
discuss one's views of the law
how one would go about conducting legal
interpretation
or one's philosophy as a judge
judge jackson isn't nominated to be a
district judge or a circuit judge this
time around
so it is not enough to say that she will
approach
things with integrity and fairness and
faithfully apply precedence set by
higher courts
just as you wouldn't hire a teacher who
refused to say anything about their
teaching philosophy other than that they
would look at the curriculum and
appropriately teach the students
it's not enough to say only that one
would look at the facts and arguments in
the case and fairly apply the law
that wouldn't tell us anything about how
one plans to do the job
how one interprets the law how one
understands our constitution
it's no secret that i voted against
judge jackson's nomination to the
circuit court last year but i want to
give her the opportunity to show why i
should vote for her this time
so i want to be clear about what would
convince me to support any supreme court
nominee
i'm looking for a justice who will
uphold the constitution
not use it to invent new so-called
rights
i'm looking for a justice who
understands the constitution means what
it says and does not mean what it
doesn't say someone who understands it
is not up to nine
unaccountable unelected politicians in
black robes decide some new evolving
meaning of the constitution
based on public opinion polling or views
of the legal elite
i'm looking for a justice who realizes
that a so-called living constitution
really means that the constitution is
dead
instead we should have an enduring
constitution as justice scalia contended
i'm looking for a justice who
understands that there is a process for
updating the constitution and that
process is by amending the constitution
i will not support anyone who seeks to
rewrite the constitution from the bench
rather than through our constitutional
amendment process
i'm looking for a justice who
understands that nobody is above the law
and will not coddle criminals or put
illegal aliens ahead of american
citizens
looking for a justice who will protect
the right to life of innocent infants
instead of caving to the abortion lobby
creating whole new swaths of law
out of whole cloth
i'm looking for a justice who will make
decisions based on the law
not based on their personal experiences
or preferences
not on empathy not on desired political
outcomes
but on the law and the constitution
if judge jackson is confirmed her job
will be simple
leave the legislating to congress
and to elected accountable office
holders in our states
and our municipalities
zealously protect the separation of
powers and don't overturn laws unless
they violate the constitution
i look forward to these hearings thank
you very much
thank you senator cotton senator booker
of new jersey thank you very much mr
chairman
judge your honor it's very good to see
you forgive me when you were in my
office you were focused on the hearings
and a lot of the substance that had such
great questions i could not stop being
just joyous that you were sitting in my
office and i couldn't stop bringing up
to you the historical nature of this
forgive me i grew up in a small black
church where i was taught uh to make a
joyous noise unto the lord and this is
not a normal day for america
we have never had this moment before
and i just want to talk about the joy i
know tomorrow in the coming hearings
we're going to have tough hard questions
but please
let me just acknowledge the fact
that this is not normal it's never
happened before the senate is poised
right now to break another bat barrier
we are on the precipice of shattering
another
ceiling another glass searing it's a
ceiling it's a sign that we as a country
are continuing to rise
to our collective cherished highest
ideals
i i just feel this sense of overwhelming
joy as i see you sitting there as i see
your family sitting behind you
you know the greatness of america
is that these imperfect geniuses at our
founding founded a nation different than
any before on in human history
it wasn't because we all prayed the same
or looked the same they put forth in a
constitution the best hopes for humanity
and the story of america i think is a
testimony to this world of what diverse
people can achieve it's been said by so
many of my colleagues about the fact
that we have had
115 supreme court justices
and we shouldn't diminish the
accomplishments of mostly these 108
white men they were extraordinary
patriots who helped shape this country
but now we are seeing to the highest
court in our land
a hopeful day like this
that that so many of the people so much
of the rich talent of our nation
who could not scarcely ever dream of
sitting on the supreme court
now we are showing that we will indeed
go deep into the waters of our nation
and pull forth the best talent
extraordinary legal talent comes from
all backgrounds i know
that in our nation for the 200 plus
years of our history there have been
extraordinarily talented black people
men and women muslim men and women from
the founding of our nation
we've seen extraordinary indigenous men
and women all who probably could have
added to the greatness of our courts but
they were denied that
opportunity
i believe we say these words justice for
all but there are many of people who
feel those words have been diminished by
the lack of representation the lack of
avenues for talented people to ascend to
our courts but fortunately thanks to the
sacrifices of all americans people on
both sides of the political aisle we
have begun to see more and more
diverse americans slowly
get on to our federal courts
my family celebrated that
i was born in 1969 the year that
president johnson nominated thurgood
marshall the first african-american to
serve on the supreme court it shook the
wonderful foundations of our nations and
he became a symbol to all of us black
and white
of what a supreme court justice can be
and then ronald reagan
1981 roughly 200 plus years since the
founding of our nation put justice
sandra day o'connor that was not a
normal moment
it was a moment to rejoice
and now we've seen president obama put
justice
so sonia sotomayor the first hispanic on
the court
and what i'm seeing in this congress my
colleagues and i
doing is we are opening the doors of
diverse talent to our federal courts in
ways we've never seen before think about
this president biden has nominated the
first ever article iii muslim judge to
our federal courts
he nominated the first openly lgbtq
woman to serve on our federal courts he
nominated native american and asian
american candidates who have appeared
before this committee incredibly
talented individuals worthy of their
positions now act in roles to the
benefit of our whole nation
they herald the truth of who we are as a
country an inclusive
multicultural nation that shows the
world the promise of a true democracy
in all over two-thirds of the confirmed
judges under the byte administration
have come from groups who historically
have not been represented on our federal
courts
so for this those reasons
and more today to me is a day of joy i
cannot
tell you how happy i am
today we should rejoice
because president biden nominated
someone that we've heard
to be the 116th associate judge of the
supreme court who is extraordinarily
talented
and also happens to be a black woman
something we've never seen before
judge jackson's nomination breaks an
artificially confining mold of our past
and opens up a more promising
potential filled future for us all as
americans it signals that this nation
will draw more deeply from all of our
talent and genius that will benefit all
americans
this is the america that most of our
families speak of from all our diverse
backgrounds an america where anybody can
achieve anything
not because of the color of their skin
but because of the content of their
character and god i can't wait for
america to find out more about your
character
when the next generation behind us
looks at the highest courts in the land
this idea will be made more real and
even just the faces of the nine
you bring this wealth of experience
that's exciting to me
you've seen so many parts of our legal
system
but i just want to talk about you your
role as a public defender because that
too
is unprecedented
i have a friend uh that my uh that just
was at the prayer breakfast here in
congress brian stevenson he has this
saying he says we have a justice system
that treats you better if you're rich
and guilty than if you're poor and
innocent
i'm not sure if most americans know that
80 percent of those who go before our
nation's criminal courts
can't afford
an attorney
to this end a public defender should be
looked at as one of the most honorable
roles within our judicial system and yet
we have never had a public defender or
anyone who served as a public defender
on our highest court
and it unfortunately is very lacking
amongst all federal judges
you wrote the judge that the role of the
public defender made you a better judge
you said it gave you a chance to quote
help people in need
and to promote core constitutional
values
well the sixth amendment right to the
assistance of counsel is guaranteed
regardless of wealth and despite the
nature of the accusations
i i honor that more than you know as
someone who started in legal clinics at
yale
i had my
empathy expanded i had my understanding
of the struggles
of my fellow americans in ways that
shaped my entire professional career
i
love the fact that you have been a
bridge builder in so many ways
you have the support of republican
appointed judges and democratic
appointed judges heck you were confirmed
by the senate in a bipartisan manner
three times i love the fact that you
have the support of civil rights lawyers
and our largest police organizations
like the fop it is a testimony to what
this nation needs more of
people that will find ways not to
accentuate the lines that divide but try
to find
more
ties that bind us together
let me
go one note more personal
back to you sitting in my office
i i can't tell you how before our
meeting how many people reached out to
me with very emotional moments
you know my mom's deltas
i heard from many links sisters
i i cannot tell you what it meant to me
so when you came to my office rarely i
was a little kind of
nervous even
and
and then you started talking about your
family
and your parents i want to tell your
parents uh you and i have something in
common we're both around the same age
both of our parents graduated from hbcus
my dad
mr brown dr brown is also an eagle he
went to north carolina central just like
you
and
they came to d.c
my mom worked in the d.c public schools
mr brown just like you
and your story
the more you talked
americans from all backgrounds know what
it is to be underestimated and looked
down upon
when they told you you were too
ambitious for wanting to go to harvard
you were a mom that faced career
challenges
at your private law firm how many women
can relate to that
the more you spoke about your personal
story the more i know it is an american
story that folks from all backgrounds
can relate to
but there's something that really moved
me
behind you in your family is your
daughter leila
and when she was 11 years old i love
this
she wrote a letter to president obama
urging him to nominate his
her mother you to the united states
supreme court
wow and in that letter her
recommendation put forward
that you judge jackson would be quote a
great supreme court justice
i suspect after these proceedings and
please god
after your confirmation the supreme
court something new will happen in
america
that that letter from your daughter will
not be exceptional
generations of little young girls and
generations of little young boys no
matter who their parents are will have
the audacity to write the president of
the united states
whether they're daughters of white
parents or black parents or biracial
parents or muslim and jewish parents
sick or hindu parents we're going to see
a new generation of children talking
about their mamas
and daring to write to the president of
the united states of america that my mom
should be on the supreme court
well i want to tell your daughter right
now
that that dream of hers is so close to
being a reality some tough days ahead
but
i think it could happen
and your grandparents generation
literally this week back in 1965
when my parents were
in washington dc
and that
week
there was a man named martin luther king
who began on this day of march from
selma to montgomery and when he finally
made it
on the 25th of march
he
talked to people who are losing faith in
america that we can be who we say we are
and he says
for those folks how long will we have to
wait not long because the ark of the
moral universe is long and it bends
towards justice
well today
america is witnessing
the literal bending of the ark
and the conducting of one of the most
sacred ideals of this country justice
for all i think more people at the end
of these hearings and after a senate
vote more people will believe
that we can be the nation we say we are
when we put our hand on our heart
indeed i think you
and your family are giving a lot more
people
faith
that we will achieve a nation of liberty
and justice for all thank you thank you
senator booker
senator kennedy of louisiana
hello
hello judge
um if you are
a lawyer or an american i guess it
doesn't
get any bigger or better than this
congratulations
um
in addition to honoring
the wonderful state of minnesota
and unless you correct me i am going to
assume
that your uh
your purple attire is also meant to
honor lsu
in my state
and if i squint real hard it i might
call it marion blue
the colors of
my southern university in louisiana
um i want
i want to compliment you and the biden
white house
for uh
selecting senator doug jones to advise
you
senator jones knows the senate
and the senate knows senator jones
and we
know him to be quite the intellect
but more important
we knowing to be a person of good
judgment and good will
and i'm
i'm glad that you've been listening to
him
um
i hope we will be able to use this
hearing today to talk about if not
implicitly at least implicitly
uh two subjects
the first is the legitimacy
of the united states supreme court
um
where does the court get its legitimacy
what can we do to enhance it
judicial
legitimacy is important
i don't need to tell you that
i'm rather fond of the constitution
i know you are too
when members of the united states
supreme court interpret it
i want the american people to believe
them i want the american people to say
well
i may not agree but the men and women
who made that decision are
intellectually honest and people of good
faith
one of the primary roles of the united
states supreme court is to uphold the
rule of law
and sometimes
justices i have to uh uphold the rule of
law when it's not popular
sometimes justices have to uphold the
rule of law when it's not
popular with the majority of americans
boy that's tough
uh it's also important
um
sometimes not generally but sometimes
the majority can mean that just
all the fools are on the same side
and that's what the courts are for
and
i'm rather fond of the bill of rights
too and i know you are as well
i've never believed that the bill of
rights
was there for the
for the high school quarterback
or the prom queen
they're covered by it
but the bill of rights is there to
protect the rights who of people who
don't see the world exactly like
everybody else
or who don't look
exactly like everybody else
now unfortunately through history we
have had people
some well-intentioned
who tried to de-legitimize
the supreme court
um we had a president way back when who
tried to impeach a supreme court justice
we had another president
who wanted to pack the court
i remember the impeach earl warren signs
in the warren court
um
and and most of the people who want to
de-legitimize the supreme court
believe that the uh
unlike our founders and my judgment
believe that um
that that members of the supreme court
ought to be ought to be and are
politicians and robes
they believe that the united states
supreme court ought to be a mini
congress
they believe that the law
is not the law the law supposed to just
be politics practiced in a different way
and they believe in court packing
and they're wrong
number two i hope today that we can use
this as an opportunity
to talk about if not explicitly at least
implicitly that's what i'm going to try
to do
the appropriate balance between
representative government
and declarative government
now in representative government as you
well know
um
people through their elected
representatives make policy
in in declarative government
um policy is made
by the unelected the administrative
state
and the federal judiciary
now they're they're both are important
both are important i'm not saying this
is a zero sum came or either or
what's but what's just as important is
we have the appropriate balance between
representative government
and uh what i'll call deflect
declarative
government i mean we have an
administrative state did any of us ever
think it would get this big is that
healthy we need to ask ourselves that
is is it really healthy
to arrive at a circumstance where the
administrative state passes 35 laws a
year to r1
is it really healthy to have an
administrative state that makes its own
laws
interprets its own laws
and enforces its own laws
before courts
with respect to which the administrative
state appoints the judges
i think that's a fair question to ask
in terms of with respect to to to uh
declarative government and the supreme
court and and the federal judiciary
uh federal judges have enormous power
they have to but they do they have
enormous power
you're appointed for life
you can't be unelected
your salary can't even be reduced
and you have to have that power
judicial power is important
so is judicial restraint
i believe
that the appropriate role of the federal
judiciary
is the following
federal judges
make law
they don't tell us what the law ought to
be
they tell us what the law is
now i said primarily
because of course sometimes federal
judges may call
i mean you make the law of the case you
decide a case
uh you have to tell us what reasonable
means in terms of searches and seizures
you have to help us to find restraint of
trade after we pass a statute so of
course judges
may call
but i'm talking about uh
about the uh the proper balance i'll
leave you with the these last thoughts
um and then i'll yield back my time
um
i want you to hear the words of warner
and what
my in my opinion is is
is one of our most distinguished
supreme court justices i'mma read it
read his words
the american people love democracy
and the american people are not fools
the people know their value judgments
are quite as good as those taught in any
law school
maybe better
value judgments after all
should be
voted on
not dictated
i look forward judge
to getting to know you better
and
congratulations mom and dad
thanks senator kennedy senator padilla
thank you mr chair
judge jackson
welcome back
to the senate judiciary committee
now uh the last time you were before us
just less than a year ago
uh i recall that you mentioned that
every once in a while
you make it a point to
walk a few blocks from your courthouse
to the national archives
as we all know
the national archives is where
the declaration of independence
the constitution
and the bill of rights
are housed
you share that uh
you
go there and reflect on the
momentousness
of the office that you hold
and it's a fitting place these archives
to be reminded of our nation's highest
ideals
our pursuit of a union that is more fair
that is more free
and that is striving to be more perfect
it's also a place to see how for two and
a half centuries
our democracy has remained
a work in progress
and that it's incumbent upon all of us
yes as a
nation but each of us as individuals to
continue
making that progress
now the men who
wrote our founding documents
could never have imagined
that you would one day be here
a former public defender
a proud graduate of a public high school
a working mom
and yes the first black woman nominated
to serve on the nation's highest court
colleagues our founding fathers also
could never imagine that
the senators sitting before judge
jackson
would include the first women
to represent california hawaii and
tennessee
the first jewish man to represent
georgia
the first hispanic man to represent
texas
the first black man to represent new
jersey
nor could they have imagined that the
list would include me
i'm here as a proud son of immigrants
from mexico
who came to this country with little
formal education
but with big dreams
and a tremendous work ethic
and it's because of the decades of hard
work and sacrifice by
santos and lupe padilla
my dad is a short order cook my mom as a
housekeeper
that i've enjoyed tremendous
opportunities in my life
and that includes the honor of
representing the state of california in
the united states senate
and of being the first latino to do so
so like so many of us in this room
i'm blessed to live
the american dream
now looking around you can see that the
strides that our democracy has made
toward strengthening our institutions by
including
more voices and more perspectives
judge jackson if you're confirmed we'll
take another step towards making our
government better reflect the america
that it serves
towards making the promise of america
more real
and we know that progress
doesn't come easily
breaking barriers and being the first
means not just significant opportunity
but tremendous responsibility
but judge jackson i also know you're
equipped
with a tremendous record of experience
and accomplishment
and you are ready
to blaze this trail
a trail that your grandparents
may have found unfathomable
but one that your daughters
and my sons
and future generations
will now see as a natural part
of the american story
judge jackson even before
your next opinion or dissent
your appearance before us today already
begins a new chapter in our nation's
history
and i can say for certain that by the
end of these hearings
those watching across the country
will know of your outstanding
qualifications your experience
and your accomplishments
which bear repeating over and over again
a public education including graduating
from miami palmetto high school
i see that smile
followed by degrees from harvard college
and harvard law school
clerkships at the federal district court
the federal court of appeals and the
united states supreme court
two years as a federal public defender
two years as a staff member of the
united states sentencing commission and
four years as its vice chair
you've been confirmed by this senate
not once
not twice
three times
each on a bipartisan basis including two
lifetime judicial appointments
and you bring nearly a decade of
judicial experience which by the way is
more than the combined total of four of
the currently sitting justices at the
time
they were nominated
so yes you are clearly
more than qualified to serve as a
justice of the supreme court of the
united states
and yes
you bring a wealth of other important
experiences and perspectives to the
court
including as a working mother and as a
black woman
now in these hearings i look forward to
speaking further about your background
your experiences both on and off the
bench
and your approach to the law
but based on our conversations already
in my review of your record
i believe
you have the expertise
the insight
and the heart
to elevate the weighty deliberations of
the supreme court
now every year the supreme court decides
dozens of cases that shape the
fundamental rights and lives of the
american people
only a small percentage of those cases
will ever be highlighted in history
books make the front page of newspapers
or go viral on social media
but the choices of the supreme court
will certainly shape the future of labor
rights
voting rights
women's rights criminal justice
immigration
technology environmental protection and
so much more i also want to be clear
about something important
if you're confirmed
i don't expect to agree with every
detail of every decision that you make
that's not my test
that is not our test
our job on this committee is to make
sure that the next justice will honor
the rule of law
and the principle of equal justice for
all
we must ensure that the next justice
will help the supreme court live up to
its responsibility to the american
people
and yes america is watching
america is watching these hearings to
see what the future holds not just for
themselves but for the court as well
judge jackson like you i believe in the
greatness and the promise of this nation
i believe that we can continue building
on our dream of a more perfect union
and that includes building a government
that better reflects and represents the
people that it serves
it's a dream that we've spent two and a
half centuries
struggling to realize
and while this hearing may not be the
last step on that journey it is a
momentous step forward indeed
just jackson you're an outstanding
nominee for our nation's highest court
and i thank you for your service and i
thank you for sharing your faith in
america's promise
of faith that is stronger because you
know how far our nation has come
and mr chair
before closing and with your indulgence
i'd like to share a few words in spanish
on the importance of this nomination
la
cortez de casos
judge jackson
i look forward to your testimony over
the next few days and i thank you mr
chairman
muchas gracias senator padilla
nada
senator tell us
thank you carolina thank you mr chairman
and uh and ranking member uh
it's a real honor to now participate in
my fourth supreme court nomination and
confirmation process and judge jackson
congratulations on your nomination i
i do feel like uh you and your family
have every reason to be very proud um
and your daughter apparently has pretty
weighty letter writing skills uh
um
[Music]
when we met together i want to thank you
for the time we spent together asked
about your family you beamed with pride
i can understand why you have parents
brothers i'm sorry siblings family
members who are public servants
themselves and now you've gone on to do
that continue that legacy with your
pa in your public defender role and as a
judge you should be very proud of that
and we should also recognize the
historic nature of this
event
the first african-american female to be
put forth for confirmation for the
supreme court is quite extraordinary
i also want to recognize that
when we had
the meeting in my office i asked you why
on earth are you doing this because this
week is not going to be particularly fun
every moment of it
why on earth are you doing this i mean
you're brilliant you're well educated
you're studied in the law
there are so many other things that you
could do
and you said that it really is the
pinnacle of your profession and that i
guess in many respects this is a
realization of a dream of yours but i
also think that it's probably putting
within reach
for many young boys and girls young men
and women the reality that they too
someday could be here before
the senate being considered for
confirmation to the highest court in the
land
so you're not only fulfilling your
dreams you're making the dreams of
others
appear to be within reach um
i think as we go through this hearing
this week we're also going to get an
opportunity to see the content of your
character demonstrate it i for one
think you have a strong track record of
ethical values honesty integrity
respecting others and endeavoring to be
fair just and compassionate
you know confirming a supreme court
justice is one of the most important
responsibilities i think i have as a u.s
senator
the outcome of our decision will impact
millions of lives and the very structure
in the future of our constitutional
republic
supreme court justices must find answers
to some of the most pressing
constitutional and legal questions of
our time
they're confronted with complex
questions many of them don't have good
answers or at least easy ones
that's why it's critical whenever a con
we confirm a supreme court justice we
understand the nominee's judicial
philosophy
and then reconcile it with our
conception of the best mindset to bring
to the bench
in my opinion
a justice's job is to interpret the text
and words of the constitution as written
and give them their original meaning
i reject the notion that the
constitution is a living evolutionary
document that changes based on the
impulses of five
unelected justices
a good judge must understand that his or
her job isn't to legislate from the
bench and read in their preferred policy
outcomes into statutes
if the words of the statute are clear a
good judge will reach a decision based
on those words
and those words alone
even if it creates an outcome they may
disagree with personally
in other words in the words of chief
chief justice roberts a good justice is
one
has one job calling balls and strikes
nothing more nothing less
sometimes that leads to rulings that
republicans like and democrats hate
other times it leads to rulings that
democrats like and republicans hate
and sometimes it leads to rulings that
everybody hates
but that's okay
that's really your job
as a supreme court justice
i had the opportunity to meet judge
jackson i said earlier and i also want
to thank you for your indulgence i may
have done my interviews a little bit
differently than other ones i asked some
questions and then i had all my staff
ask a number of questions i was quite
impressed with how engaged you were
with some of the former members of the
of the judiciary committee and other
staff and i even scared one person who
was just on the job a week and a half
said you got a question for the supreme
court justice and he had a question it
was a good question and you were very
adultered in your answer
i just thought you were honest and
forthcoming i wanted you to know that
i've said that in the press
i think that you have the right
temperament just based on how i've seen
you react to the questions that are not
the questions but the statements today
and also appreciate how your unique
perspective your upbringing your family
and your experiences of former public
defender have shaped your views
as i noted during your confirmation in
the supreme court or to the circuit
court i do have some additional
questions and concerns that i want to
ask about to kind of weep about what
weave together or reconcile
my conception
of the
the right
mindset for a judge going to the supreme
court
um
i i i'm concerned and will look into
questions over the next couple of days
and i will be here for the majority of
the hearing
to hear
to to kind of put together the
foundation that i need to make
ultimately make a decision on your
confirmation
so as i proceed with the hearing this
week
i'll be in attendance most of the time
except for breaks and i'll focus on
better understanding your writings
i'm in the middle of your thesis right
now should be finished by tomorrow
morning
your political activities and opinions
with the goal of determining your
philosophy and whether or not it fits
with my conception of the right
philosophy for somebody that i would
vote to confirm
i'll listen thoroughly i'll keep an open
mind
as i do with every nominee
before this committee
but at the end of the week i'll
ultimately have to conclude whether or
not i'm comfortable with putting someone
in a lifetime position
and whether that person is likely to
have the kind of philosophy that i want
i've told
justice gorsuch justice kavanaugh and
justice barrett
that i hope and i expected that they
would take opinions that would make me
mad
and that's okay i just want to know that
they do it for the right reason
i don't want an activist at either end
of the spectrum although i think some
people some folks are okay with one end
of the spectrum not the other
if we're talking about
preserving the integrity of the court
there's no place on the supreme court
for judicial activism
and the best thing that we can do here
is make sure that we have justices that
are going to be stewards of the
constitution
respectful
of the measures that we pass out of here
and call those balls and strikes
so i look forward to the hearing
tomorrow you're going to get a lot of
questions asked i do
thank all of my colleagues in advance
for being respectful
thoughtful and
and open-minded and i look forward to
hearing your opening statement thank you
mr chairman thanks senator tillis
senator ossoff georgia
thank you mr chairman ranking member
grassley
judge jackson good afternoon
good afternoon to your family
congratulations to your family
congratulations to you for your
nomination and welcome back to the
judiciary committee
i engage in these proceedings with deep
respect for the responsibility that the
senate has
to advise and consent on the lifetime
appointment of a supreme court justice
who would be responsible for
interpreting and applying constitutional
and statutory law
in the most complex and contested
nationally significant cases
the constitution was a groundbreaking
document when written and still by
today's standards as amended
considering the tyranny that prevails in
much of the world
its guarantees of liberty and privacy
and due process are exceptional as a
governing document
often in our history it has fallen to
the court through its decisions
to ensure the enforcement of those
guarantees
yet our constitution's guarantees of
individual rights and equal protection
under the law
remain too often and for too many
unfulfilled
for any colleagues who doubt this i
remind them of ahmad arbree's murder in
glenn county georgia just two years ago
when a young black man was shot dead in
cold blood on camera in the street
and the local authorities buried the
case
and looked the other way
only a massive civil rights mobilization
pressured state and eventually federal
prosecutors
to act
for any colleagues who doubt that those
promises remain unfulfilled to too many
i remind them that in my state you can
predict how long someone must wait to
vote by where they live and the color of
their skin
in practice the promises made in the
plain text of our constitution are still
too often broken for too many of our
fellow americans and so the court
remains essential
to that national process of becoming in
real life
what america is in text
today's hearing judge jackson is
evidence that this process continues
and above all a testament to you
personally
that in a nation still striving to
transcend the legacies of slavery and
segregation and institutionalized racism
through your brilliance and resilience
and hard work
you have already rendered great service
to the nation as a federal judge
and as a black woman you have overcome
deeply rooted obstacles
to earn nomination to our nation's
highest court
for the first time in history
alongside our constitution's exceptional
guarantees of individual rights and
equal protection is its exceptional
system of checks and balances
restraints on political power imposed by
the diffusion of authority across three
co-equal branches
between federal and state governments
with the president and a federal
legislature directly accountable to
voters and an independent federal
judiciary whose judges must be confirmed
by elected senators
this constitutional system has endured
and developed for nearly a quarter of a
millennium
it is resilient
but democracy remains the exception not
the norm in history and around the world
and we cannot take the survival of our
republic
for granted and so i look forward to
engaging with you
judge jackson to discuss your
perspective on the separation of powers
and the resilience of our constitution
when threatened by political actors who
would ignore the rule of law
or seek to seize power
by illegal or extraordinary means
among the court's most challenging tasks
are to grapple with unsettled law when
the stakes are highest or even
existential for individuals and for the
country
and to apply the constitution faithfully
over the long arc of history as the
world changes in profound ways and the
text
of faithful constitutional
interpretation meets new facts
new contexts and new
technologies judge jackson should you be
confirmed you may serve as a supreme
court justice
well into the middle of this century you
will rule on cases whose contours and
complexity we cannot yet
imagine and so among several areas of
interest i look forward to learning
how you will consider protections
against unreasonable search and seizure
in an age of ubiquitous surveillance
how you might approach disputes over war
powers
where law remains unsettled between
executive and legislative claims
how you will approach questions
pertaining to freedoms of speech
and of the press
and seek that confirmation
that you will apply the law faithfully
without regard for your own opinions as
my review of your extensive work to date
demonstrates
that i believe you will
this constitutional process of advice
and consent is vital to the integrity
and legitimacy of the court
and judge jackson on behalf of my
constituents in georgia
i look forward to engaging in this
process with you and my colleagues
mr chairman i yield thank you senator
assaf senator blackburn of tennessee
thank you mr chairman judge jackson
welcome
you are indeed to be congratulated and
your entire family with you and thank
you for your time to visit
i appreciated so much that and to your
daughters her best job is being mama
she likes that one and uh
but we've talked today a little bit
about the momentous
occasion that this is and bringing you
forward and indeed it is because
unlike any other federal office this is
a lifetime appointment and the decisions
that you're going to make are going to
impact
rights and freedoms of every single
american citizen
and you know president biden thinks
you're the right person for the job
but it doesn't end there
we do have that role of advice and
consent
and it is up to us to
carry that job out so
as you have heard repeatedly this is
going to be a fair and very thorough and
very respectful hearing and we're going
to work through
this process with some tough questions
but do it in a manner the respect that
you deserve
and we've talked some today about the
treatment of justice thomas and justice
kavanaugh
justice barrett who was questioned about
her faith
and whether that made her suitable for
the court and i know your faith is
important to you
we've also talked some about
janice rogers brown
and the treatment that she endured here
so we are going to be pleased to move
forward and focus on the issues that the
american people want to focus on because
they want to know about you
and how you're going to approach your
job and the decisions that you have made
in the past what you've written what you
have said and i've got a few areas
that i'm going to want to delve a little
bit further with you and we touched on
some of these
as we talked right now when i talk to
tennesseans one of the most important
things that they bring up is the issue
of parental rights
and wanting to be able to rear their
children as they see fit and moms and
dads are very concerned about this
progressive agenda that is being pushed
in some of our public schools
educators are allowing biological males
to steal opportunities from female
athletes in the name of progressivism
just last week an entire generation of
young girls
watched as those charged with protecting
them allowed a biological male to
compete and beat a biological woman at
the highest level of collegiate sports
some girls have been forced to share
locker rooms with biological males
rather than defending our girls those in
power are teaching them that their
voices don't matter they're being
treated like second-class citizens
and americans need a supreme court
justice who will protect our children
and will defend parents constitutional
right to decide what is best
for their own kids
and here we need a little clarity
at a time when these parental rights
appear to be under assault by the
radical left
your public comments about and i'm going
to quote you
looks like i came back at a great time a
progressive education
end quote these are deeply concerning
you serve on the board of a school that
teaches kindergartners five-year-old
children
that they can choose their gender and
teaches them about so-called white
privilege i guess we're in the critical
race theory an organization called
kindergarten and pushes an anti-racist
education program for white families
your public endorsement of this type
progressive indoctrination
of our children causes one great concern
when it comes to how you may rule on
cases involving parental rights parents
also know that it's only a matter of
time before we have the next pandemic
and they're concerned about more mass
mandates or lockdowns from unelected
bureaucrats that would harm their
children's mental health and stunt their
development the american people want a
supreme court justice who will protect
their families freedoms
not allow government overreach into
private family decisions
now moms that i'm speaking with raise
the issue of crime and you've
consistently called for greater freedom
for hardened criminals at the start of
the coveted 19 pandemic you advocated
and again i quote for each and every
criminal defendant in the d.c department
of corrections custody should be
released
that would have been 1500 criminals back
on the street if you had had your way
and you used the covet 19 pandemic as
justification
to release a fentanyl drug dealer a bank
robber addicted to heroin
and a convict who murdered a u.s marshal
into our this is worse than cruz yeah
your efforts to protect convicts began
long before
the pandemic
you used your time and talent
not to serve our nation's veterans or
other vulnerable groups
but to provide free legal services to
help terrorists get out of gitmo and go
back to the fight you also even
republicans have said those people do
deserve a defense attorney renders
lighter sentences
on average you sentence child porn
defendants to over five years below the
minimum sentence recommended by the
sentencing guidelines and you have
stated publicly that it is a mistake to
assume that child pornography offenders
are pedophiles
your philosophy it appears is backward
on these issues restrictions on children
and families and freedom for criminals
in fact your philosophy or lack thereof
may be the root of the problem here i
was concerned during our conversation
earlier this month when you told me that
you really didn't have a judicial
philosophy
the american people deserve a supreme
court justice with a documented
commitment
to the
text of the constitution and
the rule of law
not a judicial activist who will attempt
to make policy from the bench without a
judicial philosophy a judge is legally
adrift and will be inclined to consider
policy rather than law you once wrote
that every judge has and i quote
personal hidden agendas what a vile
woman then influence how they decide
cases so i can only wonder
what's your hidden agenda
is it to let violent criminals cop
killers and child predators back to the
streets it's funny how they never wonder
what kavanaugh's hidden agenda is
governments reach into our schools and
our private family decisions
is it to support the radical left's
attempt to pack the supreme court
you have praised the 1619 project which
argues the us is a fundamentally racist
country and you have made clear that you
believe judges must consider critical
race theory when deciding how to
sentence criminal defendants is it your
personal hidden agenda to incorporate
critical race theory into our legal
system
these are answers
that the american people need to know so
we are going to look at past statements
and decisions
and seek clarification
from this committee before we make our
decisions so let me close again by
congratulating
your impressive career and your
nomination too now that i've assailed
your character i i'm congratulating you
for being here come of the confirmation
process you and your family should be
incredibly proud of all that you have
achieved your story is a wonderful
example of the american dream fulfilled
you were able to sit here today because
you were reared and built your career in
a free country
whose laws protect equal justice and
opportunity for all to ensure that
future generations can expect the same
blessings and opportunities you receive
we need justices who will be dedicated
to justice and the rule of law
our questions to you over the coming
days are going to be tough but they're
tough by necessity because it is our
duty to discern determine whether you
will first and foremost uphold the
constitution and our nation's founding
principles thank you so much for joining
us what a pleasure senator blackburn all
committee members have now completed
their opening statements
at this point in time we're going to
have a little shuffle of logistics and
i'll ask that the two introducers please
come forward to the witness table
judge jackson you can take a brief rest
from the glare of the spotlight
we're fortunate today to have two
distinguished guests introducing judge
jackson dear god we will hear from judge
thomas griffith who served as a judge on
the u.s circuit court of appeals for the
district d.c circuit
from 2005 to 2020
and professor lisa fairfax who serves as
a presidential professor and co-director
of the institute for law and economics
at the university of pennsylvania cary
law school
judge griffith we will start with you
make sure your microphone is turned on
it's there's a reason sir yes sir
how's that been a while since you've
been here okay
chairman durbin ranking member grassley
and members of the senate judiciary
committee
i come here today as a retired federal
appeals court judge with 15 years
of experience on the united states court
of appeals for the d.c circuit
i come here as a jurist appointed by
republican president george w bush
and i come here as someone who
understands that there are few greater
responsibilities under the constitution
than serving as a justice on the united
states supreme court
it takes a jurist of high character
keen intellect
deep legal knowledge and broad
experience to ensure that the judiciary
plays its unique role under the
constitution
to uphold the rule of law impartially
and not to be in the words of justice
stephen breyer
partisans in robes
today i have the high honor to introduce
judge katanji brown jackson a jurist who
has all of those qualities
when president biden introduced her to
the nation a little over three weeks ago
their american people caught their first
glimpse
of judge jackson's character you may
recall
that she began her remarks with an
expression of her faith in god
and her gratitude for this nation which
she rightly observed is the greatest
beacon of hope and democracy the world
has ever known
i first met judge jackson in 2013
after the senate had confirmed her
nomination to the federal district court
as a trial judge eight years later she
joined the d.c circuit as an appellate
judge after another senate confirmation
i've had many opportunities to resu to
review her work and observe her work
over the years a judge and on several
occasions i reviewed her decisions on
appeal
although we did not always agree on the
outcome the law required i respected her
diligent and careful approach her deep
understanding and her collegial manner
indispensable traits for success as a
justice on the supreme court
about her collegial manner that
important feature of the justice's work
is often
overlooked although appointed by
different presidents the justices have
genuine fondness and respect for one
another we saw some of that in their
expressions of admiration and love
for justice breyer when he announced his
retirement
the civil manner in which the justices
debate the large and vexing issues
before them is vital not only to the
success of the supreme court
but to the success of our nation
the constitution requires that of all of
us
it goes without saying that civility of
debate and respect for the differing
views of others are sorely lacking from
our public life
judge jackson's life has modeled these
qualities
perhaps most important judge jackson is
an independent jurist who adjudicates
based on the facts and the law
and not
as a partisan
time and again
she has demonstrated that impartiality
on the bench
sometimes ruling in favor of the
government sometimes ruling against the
government sometimes ruling in favor of
the individual sometimes ruling in favor
of the corporation
her rule is simple
follow the law
now some think it noteworthy that a
former judge appointed by a republican
president would enthusiastically
endorse a nomination to the supreme
court by a democratic president
that reaction is a measure of the
dangerous hyper partisanship that is
seeped into every nook and cranny of our
nation's life and against which the
framers of the constitution warned us
there should be nothing unusual about my
support for a highly qualified nominee
who has demonstrated to her life's work
her commitment to the rule of law and an
impartial judiciary
my former former colleagues in the
federal judiciary michael ludig this
guy's been blue pilled huh david levy
and andrew gilford each appointed by
republican presidents and all
highly respected judicial conservatives
have also voiced their strong support
for judge jackson's confirmation
there was a time not so long ago when
bipartisan support of the president's
nomination of a highly qualified jurist
was regular order
antonin scalia was confirmed by the
senate
98 to nothing
ruth bader ginsburg by a vote of 96 to
3.
the rule of law is a fragile possibility
in the best of times
today
it is literally
under attack in ukraine
and is threatened around the world and
in our own country
by autocrats and their sympathizers who
give lip service to the rule of law but
then work to undermine it at every turn
as justice scalia taught us so well for
so long an indispensable indispensable
feature of the republic the constitution
created
is an independent judiciary of judges
who have taken an oath
not to a president or a party but to the
american people
and to god
that they will be impartial
judge katanji jackson brown has
demonstrated her unwavering commitment
to that oath
i applaud this exceptional nomination
which i encourage the senate to confirm
thank you
professor lisa fairfax
this is judge jackson's family here for
people wondering
and members of the senate judiciary
my name is lisa fairfax
i am a presidential professor of law at
the university of pennsylvania school of
law and co-director of its institute for
law and economics
prior to my academic career i worked at
corporate and securities law at a large
law firm
but before that i was roommate and a
very dear friend at harvard college and
harvard law school of judge katanji
brown jackson
who i am so very honored to introduce to
you today and to the american people
katanji and i met during our first days
of college nearly 35 years ago
those first moments when you wonder i
won't lie the husband looks stressed and
who wouldn't be
after that diatribe from blackburn
god and unyielding love for family
katanji defines friendship
she's the friend you're immediately
drawn to for their outgoing and friendly
nature
as our circle of friends grew she's the
one who became the rock for us all
even though we are the same age she is
the role model who makes you believe in
what she said
you can do it and here's how
and she showed us how
by the power of her example of hard work
preparation and excellence that
transforms the seemingly impossible into
the achievable
together we poured our souls into our
studies
graduating college with honors and then
doing it all over again when we enrolled
and graduated law school with honors
we became sisters
and saw each other's families as our own
we both met our husbands when we were
students
and we were there for each other as we
walked down the aisles started our legal
careers and eventually our lives as
working mothers
my husband roger fairfax now dean of
american university's washington college
of law has described katanji's
impeccable credentials that's
distinguished her at every level of her
professional career
he also knows her as one of our
children's most favorite people in the
world
our college roommate nina simmons a top
corporate lawyer has described katanji's
unwavering work ethic
she puts her head down and gets it done
even
and perhaps especially when no one is
watching
our other college roommate antoinette
coakley a distinguished business law
professor has described katanji as a
coalition bill i mean fine a republican
appointee thinks that she's qualified
but have we gotten her lsat yet she
seemed destined to be a judge
because of her ability to see all sides
and render fair and level-headed
decisions
but our tight new group of girlfriends
also knows that there's so much more to
katanji beyond her brilliant mind
there's her wonderful sense of humor
her gift of storytelling her heart of
gold that always shows up
from the first call you make for advice
about your career
to the first knock you here on the door
after learning you're diagnosed with
cancer you never have to ask she is
always there
above all katanji is humble enough not
to pretend she knows how to have it all
but she does know how to give it her all
at what she gives to her family
her friends
she also gives to the law and to this
country
a testament of her character is all the
people of different backgrounds and
beliefs who understand that essence of
katanji
we've seen that in her endorsements from
bipartisan colleagues from the bench and
the bar and from both civil rights
leaders and members of law enforcement
and we will see it in the history she
will make
i know she is honored and humbled by the
significance of this moment
not for what it means for her
but what it means for our amazing
country
confirmation of the idea that america is
a place in which all of us can feel a
sense of belonging and all of us can
reach our fullest potential
while challenging
i would summarize nearly 35 years of
friendship in this way
by highlighting katanji's faith in god
and country
her intellectual brilliance
her goodness and grace
and a work ethic
that makes her perfectly suited for the
serious task of serving on the supreme
court
it is with tremendous pride love and
gratitude for her willingness to serve
that i introduce to you my dear friend
and an exemplar of the best of america's
promise
judge katanji brown jackson thank you
thank you both professor fairfax and
judge griffith i'm sure that the judge
jackson and her family deeply appreciate
your being here today and your kind
words i want to add to the list of
introducers man sitting behind you
senator doug jones who has introduced
judge jackson to many of us not
for the first time maybe reintroduced it
but doug thank you for serving in this
cause and for helping the president and
judge jackson thank you all three for
being with us today
we are now going to move to the next
phase of the program and that is to hear
from judge jackson
so if we can set up a table
if you think this process becomes absurd
with marsha blackburn imagine if like
marjorie taylor green or lauren bobert
were here please raise your right hand
reaffirm that the testimony you're about
to give before the committee will be the
truth the whole truth and nothing but
the truth so help you god
i do
let the record reflect that the judge
has answered in the affirmative
and having met that requirement you may
now proceed with your remarks
chairman durbin
ranking member grassley
and distinguished members of the
judiciary committee
thank you for convening this hearing and
for considering my nomination
as associate justice of the supreme
court of the united states
i am humbled and honored to be here
and i am also truly grateful for the
generous introductions that my former
judicial colleague
judge tom griffith
and my close friend professor lisa
fairfax
have so graciously provided
i'm also very thankful for the
confidence that president biden has
placed in me
and for the kindness that he and the
first lady and the vice president and
the second gentleman have extended to me
and my family
today will be the fourth time
that i've had the honor of appearing
before this committee to be considered
for confirmation
over the past three weeks i have also
had the honor of meeting each member of
this committee separately
and i've met with 45 senators in total
your careful attention to my nomination
demonstrates your dedication to the
crucial role that the senate plays in
this constitutional process
and i thank you
and while i'm on the subject of
gratitude i must also pause to reaffirm
my thanks to god
for it is faith that sustains me at this
moment
even prior to today i can honestly say
that my life
has been blessed beyond measure
the first of my many blessings is the
fact that i was born in this great
nation
a little over 50 years ago in september
of 1970
congress had enacted two civil rights
acts in the decade before and like so
many who had experienced lawful racial
segregation firsthand
my parents johnny and ellery brown left
their home town of miami florida and
moved to washington dc
to experience new freedom
when i was born here in washington my
parents were public school teachers
and to express both
pride in their heritage and hope for the
future
they gave me an african name
kitanji onyika which they were told
means lovely one
my parents taught me
that unlike the many barriers that they
had had to face growing up
my path was clearer
so that if i worked hard and i believed
in myself in america
i could do anything or be anything i
wanted to be
like so many families in this country
they worked long hours and sacrificed to
provide their children every opportunity
to reach their god-given potential
my parents have been married for almost
54 years and they're here with me today
i cannot possibly thank them enough for
everything they've done for me
i love you mom and dad
my father in particular bears
responsibility for my interest in the
law
when i was four we moved back to miami
so that he could be a full-time law
student and we lived on the campus of
the university of miami law school
during those years my mother pulled
double duty working as the sole
breadwinner of our family while also
guiding and inspiring four-year-old me
my very earliest memories are of
watching my father study
he had his stack of law books on the
kitchen table while i sat across from
him with my stack of coloring books
my parents also instilled in me and my
younger brother kataj
the importance of public service
after graduating from howard university
kitaj started out as a police officer
following two of our uncles
after the september 11th attacks on our
country kitaj volunteered for the army
and eventually became an infantry
officer serving two tours of duty in the
middle east
kitaj is here today providing his love
and support as always
and speaking of unconditional love
i would like to introduce you to my
husband of 25 years dr patrick jackson
i have no doubt that without him by my
side from the very beginning of this
incredible professional journey
none of this would have been possible
we met in college more than three
decades ago and since then
he's been the best husband father and
friend i could ever imagine
patrick i love you
william patrick's identical twin brother
is here as well
along with his wonderful wife dana
also here from park city utah are
patrick's older brother gardy and his
wife natalie
and last but certainly not least
my very dear in-laws the matriarch and
patriarch of the jackson family pamela
and gardner-jackson have traveled here
from boston to be with me today
i'm saving a special moment in this
introduction for my daughters
talia and laila
girls i know it has not been easy as
i've tried to navigate the challenges of
juggling my career and motherhood
and i fully admit that i did not always
get the balance right
but i hope that you've seen that with
hard work determination
and love it can be done
i am so looking forward to seeing what
each of you chooses to do with your
amazing lives
in this incredible country
i love you so much
there are so many others who are not
here today but whom i need to
acknowledge
i have a large extended family on both
sides
they are watching from florida north
carolina new jersey connecticut new york
massachusetts colorado and beyond
i also have incredible friends three of
my college roommates came here today to
support me
and i have so many other boosters from
miami palmetto senior high school
harvard undergrad harvard law school and
all throughout my personal and
professional life i've also had
extraordinary mentors like my high
school debate coach fran berger may she
rest in peace
she invested fully in me including
taking me to harvard the first i'd ever
really thought of it
to enter a speech competition
mrs berger believed in me
and in turn
i believed in myself
in the category of great mentors
it was also my great good fortune to
have had the chance to clerk for three
brilliant jurists
u.s district judge patty sarris u.s
court of appeals judge bruce celia
and supreme court justice stephen breyer
these extraordinary people were
exceptional role models
justice breyer in particular not only
gave me the greatest job that any young
lawyer could ever hope to have
but he also exemplifies what it means
to be a supreme court justice of the
highest level of skill
and integrity civility
and grace
it is extremely humbling to be
considered for justice briar's seat and
i know
that i could never fill his shoes
but if confirmed
i would hope to carry on his spirit
on the day of his supreme court
nomination
justice breyer said quote
what is law supposed to do
seen as a whole
it is supposed to allow
all people
all people
to live together in a society
where they have so many different views
so many different needs
to live together in a way that is more
harmonious
that is better
so that they can work productively
together
end quote
i could not have said it better myself
members of this committee
if i am confirmed i commit to you that i
will work productively
to support and defend the constitution
and this grand experiment of american
democracy that has endured
over these past 246 years
i have been a judge
for nearly a decade now and i take that
responsibility and my duty to be
independent very seriously
i decide cases from a neutral posture
i evaluate the facts
and i interpret and apply the law to the
facts of the case before me
without fear or favor
consistent with my judicial oath
i know that my role as a judge is a
limited one
that the constitution empowers me only
to decide cases and controversies that
are properly presented
and i know that my judicial role is
further constrained
by careful adherence to precedent
now in preparing for these hearings you
may have read some of my more than 570
written decisions and you may have also
noticed that my opinions tend to be on
the long side
that is because i also believe in
transparency
that people should know precisely what i
think
and the basis for my decision
and all of my professional experiences
including my work as a public defender
and as a trial judge
have instilled in me the importance of
having each litigant
know that the judge in their case has
heard them
whether or not their arguments prevail
in court
during this hearing
i hope that you will see
how much i love our country
and
the constitution
and the rights that make us free
i stand on the shoulders of
so many who have come before me
including judge constance baker motley
who was the first african-american woman
to be appointed to the federal bench and
with whom
i share a birthday
and like judge motley
i have dedicated my career
to ensuring that the words engraved on
the front of the supreme court building
equal justice under law
are a reality
and not just an ideal
thank you
for this historic chance
to join the highest court
to work
with brilliant colleagues to inspire
future generations
and to
ensure liberty
and justice
for all
thank you judge jackson
well this is the end of the first day of
the first three days which
are
involving more personal on a personal
level the senators on the judiciary
committee in a way it's the easiest day
because 10 minutes is merely a throat
clearing warm-up for most senators on
this committee
starting tomorrow will be some serious
exchange in questions of 30 minutes and
then the following day 20 minutes for
each senator to participate in the wild
tomorrow we're looking forward to this
opportunity to finally really give you a
fulsome opportunity to respond to many
of the things that you've heard and to
answer direct questions
members have until thursday at five
it'll be a folsom and cocksure
opportunity we're going to reconvene
tomorrow morning at 9 00 a.m to begin
the 30 minute rounds of questions we
thank all the participants and members
of
our audience
for keeping this
dignified respectful and civilized and
we hope to continue that tradition
tomorrow that this the committee stands
adjourned so for the people who are
curious what an unqualified nominee
would look like just google george w
bush's nomination of a young lady named
harriet myers
if you want to very strongly see an
unqualified nominee
who went down in flames quite frankly
harriet myers is the name to uh
investigate
i think we would say
um we will be live live live tomorrow
for the questioning starting uh before
we'll actually i'll probably start at 8
30 at 8 30 a.m eastern
i guess we would call that 8 30 a east
5 30 a
west tomorrow
and uh we're gonna be uh i am very much
looking forward to the uh rounds of
questioning and i think she will be
eminently prepared despite
endless desires to
sandbag her
and she should be questioned in a
serious manner there's nothing wrong
with that there's nothing wrong with
that
but that will be
that will be tomorrow so i appreciate
everybody who joined coverage today
uh and we will be back with you tomorrow
that's uh the bottom line thank you
everybody
you